[Music]
homie look what I become
if no I like the guy Vincent oshana for
Choice words what about Trump
I think the highest rated program for
that show which is what was it was
showing Brazil was the highest rated
program then what was the fight all
about I saw them like what are they
fighting because obviously you guys are
not you're speaking in uh
what had happened it was right at the
height of this reporting I was doing in
Brazil that was extremely tumultuous it
was really kind of shaking the country
to its its foundations so it was very
polarizing and the person with whom I
had had this fight had gone on his own
show I think maybe
like six weeks earlier and it said
something like you know my husband
um who recently passed away but at the
time he was a member of Congress and I
was in the middle of this uh this that
doing this journalism and he said
something like what I want to know is
they have they adopted two kids they're
raising two kids who's taking care of
these kids he's a congressman he's doing
all this [__] in Brasilia the other
ones dealing with stolen documents who's
raising the kids as though it's uncommon
these days for kids to have two parents
who are working I think we need to judge
a minor judge to go and investigate
whether these kids should be taken out
of the home so if there's anything that
you know as a father someone can say
that is going to make you kind of angry
it's maybe you should have your kids
taken away from you and then when I got
to this interview he wasn't supposed to
be there they told me at the last minute
he would be
I said fine I'm happy to talk to anybody
they sat him down I don't know if you
saw the video go to 417. trust me I saw
it inches look at how close we were oh
my God like sitting on top of each other
Glenn you're ready to throw down at this
point yeah
you're sizing up his Jaws I mean I was
you know they wanted they they started
off by like hey let's talk about the
news and I said yeah before we do that
I'm gonna need an apology there we go
Glenn Greenwald getting it in right
there you'll see I did not initiate the
physical confrontation but you did
finish it though oh [__] glad glad oh
Glenn oh Glenn you gotta block your face
about to come wait wait for it five
seconds hold on five seconds
[Music]
so yeah that's the kind of thing I'm
ready for did you [__] slap him yeah I
mean it was hard you see this gigantic
guy that was like the Jerry Springer
security team holding me back so there
was only so much I could do I had never
been in a physical conversation on a
news program before it's not like I go
around engaging in fistically is this a
Big Show no yeah it's a gigantic it's
like one of the biggest shows in Brazil
let's do our best to get along today you
know you're very close to Benny he's an
agitator
I meditated this morning I also did some
workouts at good time just so we're just
talking about this one for those who
don't know let me actually properly
introduce who is here because you know
for those who know you're here you know
exactly why you're here you want to know
what's going on this man's got a lot to
say and it's uh you know he he broke the
news worldwide a few years ago so Glenn
Greenwald is an American journalist
author and former lawyer 19 1996 he
founded a law from concentrating on
First Amendment litigation he began
blogging on National Security issues on
October of 2005 when he was becoming
increasingly concerned with what he
viewed as attacks on civil liberties by
the George Bush Administration in the
aftermath of the 911 he started
contributing to Salon in 2007 then to
Guardian in 2012. in June 2013 while at
the guardian he began publishing a
series of reports detailing previously
unknown information about American and
British Global surveillance programs
based on classified documents provided
by Edward Snowden if you've seen the
movie Snowden and there's a man
interviewing Snowden it's Glenn
Greenwald okay if you've seen the
documentary is it citizen foreign
that was done about Snowden was by
Oliver Stone I think he did a good job
the documentary was filmed in real time
by it won the Oscar I think it's a
better film for those who want to know
about yeah night and day I agree and
then his work came contributed to
Guardians 2014 Pulitzer Prize win and it
was a monk a group of three reporters
who won the 2013 George Polk award
through his intercept Brazilian June in
2019 Glenn Greenwald published League
conversations between senior officials
involved in operation car wash a corrupt
case in Brazil regarding Lula and a
bunch of different things happened there
are four-time New York Times bestseller
but by far the best title you wrote of
all your books is the one I think it's
the one in 2006. how would a Patriot Act
what a great Idol right I can't take
credit for that but when I heard that
title I knew that was a winning title I
had you know I was at the time writing
for six months no one knew who I was and
that title really captured a lot of
attention
um especially given the era so uh credit
to whoever came up with that title I
forget who that was no so from from the
from the time of you doing citizen four
sitting down with him you know to now
how much progress have we made or how
much progress has CIA FBI NSA made on
being able to control what we're doing
you know it's one of the things we saw
you know at the time we did this
reporting and you know it's kind of
assumed now that the CIA and the FBI and
the NSA spying everybody at the time
people some people had suspicions of it
but there was no evidence to prove it a
lot of those of us who were saying that
it was happening were called conspiracy
theorists precisely because it was all
done in the dark with no evidence that's
what made it Edward Snowden heroic as he
came forward with the evidence to prove
it
so there was a huge movement in the year
18 months following these Revelations
for bipartisan reigning in of the NSA
the the idea that the U.S security state
was never supposed to be turned inward
onto the United States on to American
citizens it was supposed to be directed
outward there was legislation that was
co-introduced by Justin Amash who at the
time was considered the this you know
far-right tea party conservative from
Michigan who co-sponsored it with John
Conyers who was like the liberal Lion of
the house
um so it was very bipartisan it was on
its way to passing it would have been
the first ever piece of legislation to
reign in the powers of the security
state after 9 11 as opposed to expand
them
the White House the Obama White House
was adamantly opposed got Nancy Pelosi
to whip enough votes just at the last
second to defeat it narrowly there's a
foreign affairs article that says how
Nancy Pelosi saved the NSA which is
exactly what happened
um and then ever since then the U.S
Security State which is very Adept at
inventing new enemies started you know
kind of a kite at that point was sort of
tired people weren't that scared anymore
by Al Qaeda it had been 12 years since
the 9 11 attack suddenly it was Isis for
a year and a half or two that got people
scared enough to want more security and
then into 2016 Russia arrived and has
become the preeminine enemy now that
makes all American liberals practically
by pulling data love the NSA love the
sci and so a lot of this has gone
backward actually because they're very
good at propaganda at keeping Americans
afraid enough to wanting those sorts of
authorities to grow in the name of
keeping them safe and it's it's funny
you say that because um what's the last
thing he says in one of the last things
he says in the interview Snowden says in
the months ahead the years ahead it's
only going to get worse until eventually
there will be a time where politics
policies will change because the only
thing that resists the activities of the
surveillance state are policy even our
agreements with our with other Sovereign
governments we consider that to be a
stipulation of policy rather than a
stipulation of Law and because of that a
new leader will be elected
last part of this short clip they will
find the switch
say that because of the crisis
because of the dangers we face in the
world some new and unpredictable threat
we need more Authority we need more
power and there will be nothing the
people can do at that point to both
oppose it and it'll be TurnKey tyranny
do you think that's already happened
with covet and Biden I think we're very
close to that point this is I think that
the the quick history if I can just give
it to you because it's so fascinating
and relevant which was in the 1970s
after Watergate that was the first time
Congress ever began investigating like
hey what do these agencies actually do
these agencies created after World War
II with the National Security Act in
1947 there was no CIA you know in the
1920s it was all created in the 1940s
and 50s and it was all so secret the
joke was the NSA stood for No Such
agency so they had this church committee
that was a group of bipartisan members
of the Senate that investigated what
these agencies were doing and then
covered things that shocked them the
idea that we now have the capacity to
spy on every American citizen and the
head of the committee was this guy named
Frank church he was like this liberal
Democrat from Idaho but he was one of
those you know because he was from Idaho
he was a civil libertarian and what he
said was
this system is so ubiquitous and so
omnipotent that if it's ever turned
inward on the American people because at
the time the idea was still it was a
taboo to turn it inward domestically the
American people will have no place to
hide there will be no possibility left
of resisting the government because
there will be nowhere to go to be
monitored he obviously didn't Envision
the internet the surveillance
capabilities that produces which is in a
whole different universe
every whistleblower after 9 11 became a
whistleblower precisely because these
instruments now are turned inward we
know that Homeland Security and the CIA
considers not Isis or Al Qaeda or Russia
but the American people what they call
domestic extremists to be the number one
political threat and the number one
threat to our national so the whole
thing is now directed inward directed
internally that's where censorship comes
from that's where surveillance comes
from we're absolutely very close to the
point where we have a system in place
where
you cannot cross certain lines in terms
of opinions you expressed or dissonance
that you want to organize without being
called extremist and being criminalized
and that kind of turned tyranny that
really came from the 1970s that Snowden
warned about us being closer and closer
to I do think we're now rapidly
approximating and it's the reason why
the only cause I really care about at
this point is doing anything possible to
preserve Independent Media to preserve
spaces on the internet where
Independence and
um true descent can actually Thrive for
you who's in it do you see that as the
biggest threat like you know how
somebody goes to sleep they're like well
I think the biggest threat is you know
whatever climate change climate change
although your biggest threat is the
economy collapse in with the debt that
we have and what's going to happen if
deflation stagflation hyperinflation all
these things you put surveillance as
number one for you is or is that just
your cause surveillance combined with
censorship those are Because the
Internet obviously is the most powerful
an Innovative
evolution of our lifetime without
question and if you go back and read
like the triumphalus literature of the
1990s about why the internet was going
to be so revolutionary it was supposed
to be a Liber a tool of Liberation we
can communicate with each other we can
organize without the mediation of a
state centralized State and corporate
Authority what it can also be though is
the most potent tool ever invented for
monitoring and surveilling and then also
controlling the thoughts of the domestic
population and that is the term that it
has taken look I spent two two and a
half years of my life reading through
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
the most sensitive documents produced by
the most secretive agency of the world's
most powerful government that's what I
did when I got that archive by Edward
Snowden I know what their aspirations
are I know the things they say when they
thought nobody would be ever listening
and watching and then I went about
publishing them and their goal is that
kind of total and complete control that
is not enough a sort of dystopian
fantasy it's not a conspiracy that
requires I published the documents
demonstrating that that's the thing for
which they're aiming and so it's not
just my cause if we lose the ability to
dissent from establishment pieties which
we know are false we just sat through
covid for two and a half two years where
the pronouncements that came down one
after the next we now know our Falls the
same is true about the war in Ukraine
the same is true about the financial
collapse of 2008 obviously about the war
on terror it's true about every one of
our important debates if we lose the
ability to dissent from that
meaningfully meaning not just standing
on a street corner on a box but with the
ability to reach people and to organize
without being criminalized and monitored
what other political causes even
possible what's the what's an
appropriate Middle Ground like what's an
appropriate happy medium so for example
like you have
um National Security pretty you know
especially during 9 11 this whole thing
I appreciate what you're saying during
Watergate in the 70s but there's a lot
of people that are gen Z that basic I
don't remember anything yeah not even
Millennials it's all kind of catapulted
right after 9 11 uh George W bush
everything with the Patriot Act
government overreach executive powers
everything with that so how do you
grapple National Security genuinely like
trying to save the country from any
terrorist attacks or any homegrown
terrorists whatever that is versus the
surveillance State and the intelligence
Community there there needs to be a
happy medium I would assume right yeah
these these agencies have a function and
there's a legitimate function in
surveillance of course we want our
government surveilling people who mean
harm to this country that's one of their
top priorities is keeping people
physically safe there was a balance
reach during the Cold War the Cold War
was infinitely more dangerous than the
war on terror and it's obviously
infinitely more dangerous than whatever
you know fears are being cooked up all
the time about Russia or even China you
had the United States and the Soviet
Union going around the world in multiple
proxy wars with tens of thousands of
enterprise Continental ballistic
missiles that are nuclear tipped aimed
at one in other cities you can't get
more dangerous than that and during
Ronald Reagan's presidency when Dwight
Eisenhower was overseeing the Cold War
the kind of two bookends they managed to
have a system that preserved that
balance which was if we want to spy on
somebody we go to a court we get a
warrant not as high of a warrant as you
need for a criminal court because you're
spying on foreign Nationals where you
essentially say there's a legitimate
reason to be spying on these particular
groups you do it in secret if necessary
and the spying is directed which
snowden's archive revealed is that
there's nothing directed about it it's
Mass indiscriminate suspicious
surveillance an entire populations yeah
and just to add on to that it's it's
kind of almost like validate your case
like part of the surveillance State
Patriot Act or something called
um the section 215 this is where they
said the sneak and Peak provision how
familiar with that yeah well so look at
look at the Patriot Act did that is the
perfect example in the weeks and months
after 9 11 was probably like the most
traumatizing time for the country and
its history with the exception of say
the Civil War and the attack on Pearl
Harbor
but it was certainly one of the top
three and people were pretty much
willing to give the government anything
it wanted in the name of keeping people
safe 3 000 people had just died the the
Pentagon was attacked the world it's
amazing what fear will do to allow you
to basically get infringed on your right
yeah and that fear was was I lived in I
lived in Manhattan I I found that
traumatizing like watching those two
buildings collapse and under on top of
three thousand of my fellow citizens
um but even in that climate the Patriot
Act was considered so radical
that there was a lot of voices in
descent saying wait a minute this seems
pretty Un-American this legislation and
in order to justify it the province
there was a provision that was put into
it that said with all of these Powers
don't worry it's only temporary it will
expire after four years in order for it
to be renewed Congress has to come back
and declare a sufficient emergency in
order to renew it people said okay we'll
accept it only because it's sort of this
byproduct of an emerge okay here we are
22 years later no one ever talks about
the Patriot Act anymore every four years
it gets renewed without debate it just
falls into the woodwork because it's
become normalized no one thinks the
Patriot Act is radical anymore because
exactly what you said more and every
year more and more Americans don't know
a world prior to 9 11 don't know a world
in which those Liberties existed they
just accept and assume that the way
things are are the way they've always
been in the way that they have to be and
that's the same now with the censorship
regime over the Internet more and more
people are being born into a world in
which a natural that a tiny number of
Corporations work in conjunction with
the the government the U.S security
state to determine what can and can't be
said on the internet and polls show that
a lot of people want that in fact want
more of it and that's what's really
alarming is to see how effective that
propaganda you said earlier they
they want surveillance they want control
they want this they is a lot of
different things but who is they who's
at the head of the day
I think what if you look at every
society it's not a conspiratorial theory
that there's always a power center
there's an establishment there's a
whatever you want to call it the People
For Whom the society functions most
profitably the people who want most to
preserve the status quo and I think what
has happened is if you look in the past
you know we're a capitalist society that
means there's going to be a lot of
wealth inequality and when there's
wealth inequality there's always the
chance that lots of people on the bottom
end of that wealth inequality are going
to be angry they're going to start to
get agitated they're going to be
rebellious there's lots of ways to deal
with that you can appease them you can
introduce social programs you can you
know keep them just placated enough not
to Rebel on the street I think what the
choice that our current Elite has made
instead is
let them be as angry as what they want
we'll just paramilitize the society
enough with surveillance with
paramilitizing our police force so that
any kind of protest effort will be
instantly crushed and that they is
nothing more than the people who wield
the greatest amount of power in society
the people who are in control of the
mechanisms of surveillance of the
security state of the financial industry
the people who wield power and wash so
so you're like you're not putting it the
the they is the director of CIA the
director of FBI you know you direct
you're putting all of those guys as part
of they is that is that kind of what
you're saying well there's not an
individual at the top that every all
those days call yeah it's a it's a
Confluence of power centers that work in
conjunction with one another
um you know I when I was interviewing uh
vivec as I did yesterday right after
that debate the morning after the debate
one of the things he said need enough
time to elaborate on the debate but he
was saying the only word I want to wage
is on the fourth branch of government
we're only supposed to have three
and I asked him what is the fourth
branch of government and he said the
fourth branch of government is the
permanent power faction in Washington
that exists completely outside
Democratic accountability the
three-letter agencies the administrative
State those people are not there because
they've Consolidated control they're
serving a a part of a broader Elite you
know the people who have an interest in
in in ensuring that the population is
kind of tamped down that the country is
sort of controlled that stability is
maintained that it's impossible to
organize in a meaningful way if you're a
dissident and so it's not that's what I
mean it's not some cons you don't need
to imagine a conspiratorial uh Council
that meets in some underground layer
somewhere it's not out of a science
fiction film it's just based on how
societies function and that that is it
that there is an elite in society
especially one that's unequal and in
those unequal societies you can have a
power that starts to get more and more
centralized and then more and more
abused yeah but but the way I'm thinking
about it look for example you watch uh
the other day Drake to the concert and
he came out of the concert with LeBron
and his son bronny okay there is
alliances being built there right
because one of Drake's first songs was
about you know last name ever first you
know was it last name greatest first
name ever something like that right yeah
and okay so he made that song about
LeBron so there's an alliance there no
problem you watch it in movies and
you'll see you know Mel Gibson talking
to whoever you'll see Brad Pitt talking
to whoever there's a license there right
do these guys kind of just watch and say
oh that guy's becoming powerful let me
get a hold of him can we go out to
dinner together hey what do you think
about us doing this you think that's
what it is or do you think it's more the
money guys like a Larry Fink or a Soros
or the ESG crowd or you know the State
Street or you know the the black rock
and the vanguards or is it more the big
media guys well all of this is
controlled by Rupert Murdoch and you
know all these uh or now it's more the
powerful people of the zuckerbergs and
the Sergey and the Bezos and who who is
the people at the top that truly are
able to move it is there more political
power is it more spying power is it more
money which one of those is the most
powerful in your eyes I think the US
government is a government that exists
in servitude toward to economic power
um you know the use servitude towards
economics to economic power so you you
go and talk to any member of Congress
who's honest and they will tell you that
most of their time is spent either
raising money from big donors or having
their lobbyists for big donors write the
bills that is the reality of how bills
most bills in Congress simply come from
well-paid lobbyists who work for
corporations now again it's not a
totalitarian Society where you can
identify just one single power center
right now for like look at China for
example you have different Power centers
that want different things with regard
to China Wall Street's in bed with China
they don't want antagonism with China
they love having a relationship with
China where they put their low paid you
know workers in China producing their
sneakers and producing their computers
and producing their cars whereas parts
of the military-industrial complex seek
a cold war with China and more
antagonism toward China it's an example
where there's a kind of conflicting
agenda so you get those often but in
reality the government itself is a
government that is run by the people
with the most amount of money which is
essentially oligarchy and everyone who
works inside the government will who's
honest will tell you that
okay but does does it at all interest
you to want to know who the guy at the
top is like maybe this is just because
something that I I'm curious about you
know the movie again American Gangster
I'll never forget the scene where they
keep thinking the main drug dealer
selling Blue Magic is this Italian guy
and then all of a sudden they're like no
it's Frank Lucas and it changes the game
right with the soul Blue Magic do you
have any interest as a one of the
greatest investigative journalists of
our time some would put you on the top
five some would say the best during our
time for what you broke and what you had
to tell the story that guy felt he
trusted you more than anybody else to go
out there and sit with them and that
came with a lot of risk for you what you
did at a time like that does it interest
you to find out who is the Frank Lucas
of power yeah absolutely I mean in
general I think the people who are the
most powerful are the people who are not
very visible so in the cheapest most
anti-intellectual crudest form of
punditry they'll refer to Joe Biden as
the most powerful person on earth right
which is a gigantic joke and not just
because because he doesn't know his name
or where he is but because a president
is answerable to an enormous number of
actual power centers out in whose lines
he has to remain he's not the one
setting those lines he's the one
observing those lines he's a servant to
that power so yeah of course it it
interests me I don't though think
there's a kind of I don't think it's
like a pyramid where one person is
sitting at the door I think that there's
a set of power centers a set of power
centers you know we I was you know with
this Republican debate I'm sure we'll
talk about it but one of the things that
fascinated me was so you have
you know pretty much everybody on that
stage with the exception of Ron DeSantis
sort of and Vivek completely but every
single other person who's saying we want
to keep we want to support Joe Biden's
policy of sending billions and billions
and billions and billions of dollars to
Ukraine indefinitely to keep that war
going
they're saying this notwithstanding the
fact that they see the same polling data
that I see and that you see which is
that not just Americans
as a whole but conservatives and
Republicans in particular are
overwhelmingly opposed to that policy
they want no more money going to Ukraine
so the question becomes why do very
competent smart politicians who rely on
public opinion to win nonetheless
espouse in public a policy they know
most of their voters oppose and the
reason is is because the people who are
their donors the people who actually
control their candidacy without which
their candidacy cannot exist favor that
policy and so that's who they're serving
and I think in general that's so then
the question becomes well who is the top
donor who is like the single guy I mean
I think there's like a handful of
Institutions it's always you BlackRock
Goldman Sachs JP Morgan these are the
institutions that are by far the most
powerful economic or organs they need
and rely on the government they're
constantly working with the government
you have the arms industry of course
that also wields a lot of that power so
I think it's a small number of power
centers that in general have an aligned
interest so the way you put it this this
is how it makes sense to me on how
you're perceiving what's going on
there's kind of like the Italian mafia
many years ago when he came out with the
commission I don't know if you know the
whole commission with the five Gambino
Colombo everybody came in and say hey
guys let's control the whole thing
together we're gonna have to share some
of it and so one of the families maybe
the Black Rock State Street you know
those are the one the family is going to
be more the CIA NSA FBI one of the
families going to be more the political
power all those guys that's kind of how
you see that that happen because we all
benefit more when we're kind of working
in Confluence as opposed to and perfect
then my question for you becomes with
that and my question then my question
with that becomes uh you were going to
say it's not a definition of an
oligarchy full of people at the very top
running the whole thing if you ask me to
describe the United States in terms of
how it functions with one word I would
pick oligarchy so yeah let's go sorry
Pat but here's here's where I'm going
with that so as good as they may be at
protecting how they communicate with
each other
I'm convinced the best hackers are the
ones that don't work for the government
how are the best hackers in the world
not hacking into seeing how they
communicate with each other to release
it to the rest of the world to know what
they're saying to each other the the
technology exists for them to realize
these days when they communicate to
decide what's going to happen to the
world the next 10 20 40 50 years
shouldn't we know about it why don't
hackers Target that
because once you know how the Wikileaks
informational League were like wait what
wow I'm glad I know holy [__] so Hillary
paid 35 million so this is this so that
happened over here that's crazy why why
isn't a certain certain group of you
know
individuals who are hackers come
together and say look let's kind of find
out what these guys are doing let's get
to the truth the truth of it we can
figure it out why don't they do that
well first of all there has been an
amazing recruitment effort especially in
the wake of Snowden to recruit the top
scientific hacking Talent into the
government with all and and I mean when
we talk about the government so much of
what the government is is actually the
private sector you know Snowden worked
at the NSA but his employer was Booz
Allen Hamilton so these companies are
recruit on behalf of the government with
massive private sector
um pay so a lot of them have been
recruited successfully onto their side
and they also have an unlimited budget
because they have the American taxpayer
budget and we spend you know 75 billion
dollars at least that's what it was the
last uh secret budget that I saw is
probably 110 120 billion dollars a year
now and a huge amount goes into
defensive hacking skills as well but you
have had hacking into Power centers when
you've had you know the Pandora papers
and the Panama papers showing how the
extremely wealthy keep their money and
evade taxes you've had obviously you
know hacks into the Democratic National
Committee and Hillary Clinton's campaign
so I'm not I don't think there's some
secret counsel where the head of JP
Morgan and the head of BlackRock and the
head of Raytheon meet at some sort of
table sitting around like this and have
minutes to the meetings and then keep
them secret and the question is why
don't they leak it is a good question to
ask why do we not know more about those
kinds of uh Power centers and I think
the reason is is because the people
whose responsibility would be to do that
kind of digging is not the US government
who's working for those institutions it
would be media corporations people like
me investigative journalists are
supposed to be aimed at those power
centers and what we have instead is a
media that is not aimed at Power centers
but is aimed at working for those power
centers as well so who is it that's
going to kind of do that sort of digging
we do know enough we have gotten enough
of a glimpse into how a lot of this
works
um but we have a media that's designed
to obscure it to distract from it that's
not interested in it to minimize it to
disparage it
um look at what they did with the
Twitter files you know we got this
because of Elon Musk opening up the
corporate files of Twitter we got this
extraordinary insight into this channel
between the CIA FBI DHS on the one hand
and big Tech on the other and
immediately the employees of the largest
media corporations swooped in like they
were programmed and writing reading from
the same script and they all said this
is a nothing Burger ignore this there's
nothing here of any interest and when
you have the media that corralled and
that controlled even when you do get
those glimpses you can minimize and
neutralize them quickly so go with that
go with Twitter files I do want to come
back to ESG but since you said Twitter
files I think there's a perfect
transition to one of the questions I had
for you
do you think there's a concern with guys
like a vivec or a trump getting back in
there I'm not quite sure about the
Santas whether he would do this or not
because I think the centers would still
play Within the rules
to think a vivec or a trump getting in
there there's a possibility just like
there's Twitter files for there to be
CIA files for there to be FBI files for
there to be you know where they're
sharing here's what the FBI did here's
what the CI did holy [__] dropped the
bomb or do you think these guys going to
get in and they're going to say I'm
going to do this and I'm going to do
that and then they get and they say
listen man look you can do CIA files if
you want no problem you do FBI files for
the rest of History us will not have
credibility with the world you will be
known as the president that destroyed
America do you want that as a legacy so
one do you think there is that fear too
do you think even if that happens the
people of power like listen we know
exactly what to tell that guy we know
the script to make sure he doesn't
continue and pursue the CI and FBI Files
you know what I'm asking yeah absolutely
like here's for me the biggest dilemma
which is if you have a career politician
people have been around Washington
forever it's almost certain they're
corrupted like you cannot trust anything
that they say they're going to go in and
they're going to serve the establishment
they've been doing that for decades to
the point they've internalized the
ideology no matter what it is they're
saying then so then you have okay well
let's get Outsiders so that was the
appeal of trump right that was Trump's
appeal was I've never worked inside of
this the the inside of government before
they cannot control me
it was even part of Obama's appeal he
had been Washington for like six seconds
you know he'd been a senator for two
years when he announced that he was
running for president
I watched Obama
who I genuinely believe was had
convictions and the things he was saying
about uprooting the more extreme
elements of the war on terror the parts
that were actually infringing the civil
liberties of Americans and then the
minute he gets into office he starts
extending and protecting and even
expanding a lot of those very same
Powers he promised to uproot because
these guys in the security State they've
they're around you vote for whoever you
want that those politicians come and
leave they leave the White House they're
there they're always there they know how
to control presidents they know how to
control the political process and so the
same thing happened with Trump so often
the things that Trump was saying the
things he really meant had no
translation into Trump Administration
policy Trump was saying it's idiotic to
have troops in Syria Trump never got
troops out of Syria even though we often
ordered them out there were articles
celebrating this in the Wall Street
Journal that people in the military
would find ways to thwart his order same
thing I'm not going to arm Ukraine and
risk profit locations with Russia I want
to work with Russia I'm not going to arm
Ukraine 2017 The Washington Post
headline Trump Administration starts
sending lethal arms to to to Russia they
knew how to run circles around Trump in
part because he didn't have a good sense
of how Washington works and I think the
same thing would be with that the other
thing is they come in you know the guys
with the medals on their chest and they
say okay look I know these are the
things you were thinking and saying
before you got here but now I'm going to
show you the blood that you're going to
have on your hands if you actually start
doing these things that's right so so go
be an advisor for Trump or vivec you're
an advice for Trump or Vivek okay
and it's a real advisor not just like
hey yeah let's go find a way to win the
election and then listen I'm a president
now who cares you know we're going to do
what we're going to do you're an advisor
and and you say hey president Trump look
what they did behind you back in 2017.
look what they did behind your back with
Ukraine you look what they did behind
your back with this they don't respect
you they did whatever they just kind of
looked at it and said discuss nobody
yeah gonna be gone in four years so so
many ways so now if you truly president
Trump if you truly Vivek if you truly
whoever it is
or if if you truly want to do this
here's the five things you need to do
what would be those you know five things
you would say they need to do for that
not to happen where they're not
undermining and overlapping their
leadership I mean I think the reason why
what I mentioned earlier that Vivek said
that appealed to me so much when he said
like look the only War I'm interested in
waging is a war on that fourth branch of
government is precisely because he's not
saying I'm not going to listen to them
he's not saying I think they need to be
neutralized he's saying a war needs to
be waged on them and the question
becomes you know my the clip that I
think is if I had to show One Clip uh of
a television interview to say a Civic
student to teach them about how the
United States actually works it was that
time when Chuck Schumer went on with
Rachel Maddow shortly before Trump was
inaugurated when he was having that
Twitter war with the CIA and
accidentally spilled the truth which was
you know Schumer said Trump's being
incredibly stupid everyone in Washington
knows that if you mess with the CIA they
have six different ways to Sunday to get
back at you how is that not an instant
Scandal that the CIA has the power to
destroy an elected president that is the
reality though and so it isn't enough
just to rhetorically say the CIA is a
bad organization the CIA is something
that you you need an actual plan to
neutralize them John Kennedy had his
head blown off
um by who knows who but it certainly
came at the time that he was saying
things like I'm withdrawing all advisors
from Vietnam after he fired the most
powerful person in all of Washington
which was
um which was uh Dulles who had run the
CIA
um after the failed Bay of Pigs invasion
he never forgot that
um and that became a lesson to a lot of
people that if you want to challenge the
CIA if you want to start resisting even
minimally that's the lesson that you
should learn I have a trump question for
you yeah
are we going to the Trump topic no no I
want to stay on topic right here to with
this so
um I think we can all agree if Joe Biden
gets reelected it's a status quo nothing
changes it's just everything that we
talk about even vivec who you said you
just interviewed and Pat recently did a
town hall with who I think is an
absolute Beast he's called for a
revolution he's going after the Ford
State I think the likelihood of Evac
being the candidate is very slim yep I
think he's great he's a beast I just
don't see it happening especially while
Trump is the guy right so let's go to
Trump for a second right in 2016 you
know Trump would always say thing and I
hire the best I know the best I have the
best words I have the best ideas he's
the best the best the best I'm going to
drain the swamp I'm gonna dream to swamp
everything with that but what we
realized was that there's all these
people in power that were basically
essentially what you said not so fast uh
president Trump now if you do this you
do this now that he knows exactly how
the swamp works and all these agencies
work and now that's a different there's
a different Trump coming in he's coming
in with actual experience and basically
like like you guys screwed me the first
time well like they're trying to put him
in prison right so presumably he's like
right yes yeah let's say he gets
reelected let's say he's the guy now and
people are like well you know Mr
President here's what you need to do
he's gonna play not so fast what do you
think Trump will do differently this
time that's the 10 million dollar
question for me that I have because what
what actually happened was I mean Trump
came in spitting scorn for
neoconservatism and for the bush Cheney
operatives who you know ran the country
into the ground with these wars
um even with you know Steve bannon's
vision of what the Trump presidency was
going to look like at the beginning and
imagine if it had happened was you know
he wanted him to come in do a bipartisan
infrastructure deal with the Democrats
where you renew and rejuvenate America's
infrastructure create jobs do that as a
bipartisan president shoot up your
popularity
um even raise taxes on on the wealthy
symbolically and then you could say
you're we're using that money to build
the wall so you combine find this sort
of you know putting America back to work
domestic priorities combined with the
security at the border that people
wanted instead Jared Kushner won out of
that power battle Steve Bannon was gone
in six months Jared Kushner had a much
different ideology than Steve Bannon did
and that ended up governing the Trump
presidency Trump now says
he understands the mistakes he made the
problem I have the question that I have
is the reason those mistakes happened
and that was by far Trump's worst flaw
was you know he put Mike Pompeo who is a
classic neocon first in charge of the CA
and then letting him run the state
department so many other Nikki Haley we
just heard Nikki Haley espousing you
know Mitt Romney foreign policy from
2010 he had her as un at John Bolton
hello yeah John at least jump with John
Bolton you know Trump's excuses I wanted
a maniac at my side as a credible threat
to people but okay the problem is is
that everyone knows that Trump has a
very fragile ego and that he's easily
manipulated by flattering him and
whoever flattered him is somebody he
believes is on their side so you get
smart people like Mark Pompeo is very
smart and he comes in Mr President you
know you've convinced me this ideology
has gone wrong I'm now more of an
America First ER I think you're the one
to be the leader and suddenly he's
running the CIA the question I have is
is Trump still vulnerable to that kind
of manipulation what I saw in Brazil you
know where the reporting that I did that
you guys started off with that fun
little clip of your right hook what my
my restrained right hook which would
have been much better had I not been
restrained was
um was you know we did reporting that
had originally put you know the
corruption probe that originally put the
two-term president Lula de Silva in
prison
one of the most popular political
figures you know a giant on the
international stage they put him in
prison for 18 months and are reporting
are proved that the process was filled
with corruption and he he got out of
prison was able to run again and now
he's the president and he's filled with
vengeance and anger I mean he wants to
destroy the people I mean imagine you're
actually in a prison cell that's that's
when someone's trying to put you in
prison that makes a big difference in
terms of how you're starting to think
about your political enemies so they're
trying to put Trump in prison My Hope Is
that that really makes them understand
that you cannot have enemies inside of
your government that that character flaw
that they so successfully manipulated
has to be overwhelmed by the anger that
he has to feel over this kind of
persecution whether he really learned
that letter and whether he's capable of
it whether he's going to be surrounded
by people who help him I have a lot of
doubts about it all I can have is Hope
because I do think the chances that
anyone besides Trump will be the GOP
nominee is small how are you gonna
wrench those people away from Trump
especially with this persecution that
they continue to to impose and drive
Republican voters closer to Trump so if
he's the only chance to remove Biden the
question really becomes can Trump this
time not just talk about that Vision but
implement it and that question you're
asking is the only one that matters and
I don't know the answer to that and uh
and Glenn so you're you're you're
literally Fearless reporting 2013 with
Snowden and everything you risked
everything your name your career you
know people in your in your life were
getting detained for terrorists all that
all that stuff you knew it you risked it
you took the challenge and you did it to
wake everybody up to what the system was
doing to us right and I thank you for it
in regards to Trump do you feel his
motives to be the president are rooted
in the same ideology that you had like
meaning he said which he says all the
time he's been saying this since the 90s
I love America I love the people I'm
trying to help us do you think that's
like did he know that he was going to
get into this or was it like a sub
surprise to him like how how really bad
it was and how they were going to come
after him I mean it's never happened
before in history that a president has
gotten out of office and then been
prosecuted for anything I don't think he
could possibly have anticipated the
level of persecution to which he would
be subjected I think it's come as a
surprise but I also think that and I
know from my own experience having gone
through it you know I couldn't leave
Brazil for a year Eric holder's just
Department was telling my lawyers and we
got you know the guardian got the best
possible lawyers the kind who can pick
up the phone and get Eric called her on
the phone
if he leaves Brazil there's a good
chance he's going to be arrested we're
not giving him any guarantees as you say
my husband got detained in in the United
Kingdom with threats of a terrorism
prosecution simply because of his
association with me
um they were doing a lot of stuff and
and when you see the willingness their
willingness to just cross every line the
minute they get a little bit threatened
you're resolve increases you know you
understand they need even more
confrontation than you originally began
by believing they did if you listen to
Trump's rhetoric it's escalating in
terms of its tone in terms of its
aggression against globalist against
neocons against the people he
understands are his enemies and
I know again I hope that that is going
to have the kind of effect that I see it
having on for example president Ula who
is now taking Vengeance one after the
next kind of like uh that character in
The Game of Thrones who had our list of
of
uh the the the the small one yeah the
small daughter who had her list of you
know I hope Trump has that kind of a
list
um
because that would view the country a
lot of good if he did those are the
people that need to be destroyed there
needs to be this very uh I I want to say
violent in a metaphorical sense conflict
between these power centers on the one
hand and the and Trump who actually
threatened them for the first time in
decades on the other and it was Arya
Stark the little one and then I thought
about it and this is it's just a it's
not even a question it's no I could see
well how these Trump supporters these
magas that they like how pissed off and
because they see it and they know what
he's doing to actually help and he's
just vilified when he's he's getting mug
shots in the history of our life you
never would have thought you turn on the
news and you see the uh a president of
the United States getting a mug shot
yeah look I I actually wrote a book in
2011 arguing that this idea that former
presidents or high-ranking political
officials are exempt from the rule of
law is a huge mistake I thought the
pardon of uh President Nixon by Gerald
Ford is the thing that that this
framework in place that the country
can't handle you know Prosecuting former
presidents I think and so if this were
the case where we're finally abandoning
this idea as a principal I'd be cheering
it yeah that's not what's going on yeah
right it's a one-time only exemption for
Trump whose real crime is that he
wandered way outside of the boundaries
of what has been set for political
leaders he questioned the most taboo
subjects of the U.S Security State from
why do we still need NATO to why are we
doing regime change Wars to why do we
have to treat Russia as an enemy and
when you start doing that really messing
with their core pieties they're showing
now what they're what they're willing to
do big time uh Glenn so let's let while
we're on this topic before we go into
the mug shot
um there's a there's a lot of people you
know New York Times 27th I don't know
what it was 2017 New York Times came out
and did an article saying or no 2020
they came out USA Today Was 2017 about
you know Obama's surveillance on Trump
and they were kind of monitoring what he
was doing and you know Obama
administration secretly launched a
surveillance operation on Trump campaign
this is New York Times and they say well
it's misleading not necessarily happened
they're kind of trying to protect Obama
but then USA Today in 2017 if you type
in the same thing Rob you'll see an
article about USA Today in 2017 way
before New York Times did it the article
for USA Today says was Obama
administration illegal
spying worse than Watergate okay so this
is 2017 May 30th
from from your your you know
investigation into stuff like this I
mean this is right up your alley what
was the biggest difference between what
Nixon did versus what Obama did
uh they're they're not comparable in the
sense that the so and it's just such an
example of the extent to which we're
talking about what establishment power
centers are doing to Trump what the
media has been willing to do in the name
of stopping Trump is the thing that
sickens and offends me the most maybe
because I actually it's a profession I
thought it was joining and you know
really still do believe in the virtues
of it when it's done correctly
but the idea that the Obama
Administration was first spying on the
Trump campaign and people associated
with him and then secondly abusing the
powers of the FBI in the Justice
Department in order to help Hillary
Clinton win was widely mocked and
vilified by almost the entire media as
some sort of obvious lion conspiracy
turns out all you have to do is look at
the facts
the FBI got caught
spying on Carter page who was a foreign
policy advisor to the Trump campaign in
2016 and they didn't just get caught
spying on him in order to spy on him
they went to the fisa court and they
filled out affidavits filled with lies
to justify the spying to the point where
the FBI lawyer who did it pled guilty to
crimes because lying to the fisa court
is a crime that alone the fact that the
FBI under Obama got caught spying on an
American citizen who was an advisor to
the Trump campaign based on the lies
that the FBI told to justify that spying
ought to have been one of the biggest
political scandals in our nation's
history but then you add on to that the
fact that we absolutely now know that
the entire russiagate Scandal obviously
using scare quotes for it we just got a
report from uh the Durham report that
lays it out in 300 150 Pages they never
had anywhere near a sufficient predicate
even to open that investigation the
investigation that dominated our
politics from the mid-2016 when Hillary
Clinton first did a McCarthy nefarious
campaign ad who is what what is this
secret dark relationship between Trump
and Moscow all the way through 2018 when
the Mueller investigation closed while
arresting and convicting not a single
American of the Court crime of colluding
with the Trump campaign and with the
Russians and explicitly saying there's
no evidence to support the conspiracy
theory that the media pushed as the top
political story for three years there
was never any legal predicate for the
FBI even to open that investigation said
one of the most respected prosecutors
Federal prosecutors in the country again
this is what I was saying earlier with
their ability to just minimize and
dismiss stories away of course that's
bigger than Watergate Watergate was a
low-level break-in of the democratic
party head headquarters that produce
very little of value we're talking here
about the abuse at the highest levels of
FBI with agents who are saying in text
to one another we have to do everything
to stop Donald Trump and then having
those exact same agents open an
investigation for which there was never
an illegal basis and it didn't just have
it wasn't just an investigation that
went nowhere it dominated our politics
for three years Russian gate was the
number one story used to sabotage first
the Trump campaign and then the Trump
presidency that came from the U.S
Security State that saw Donald Trump as
an enemy and decided to abuse its core
powers in order to sabotage a candidate
that they overtly disliked why is that
not a scandal of the highest proportion
why isn't it because we have a media the
media first of all was an active
participant in it the way that it
happened was the CIA and the FBI every
day would call the New York Times And
The Washington Post and feed them the
leaks the anonymous evidence-free leaks
that became the foundational assertions
of russiagate so the media participate
they gave themselves pulitzers for it
there there are New York Times The
Washington Post reporters with shelves
like these with pulitzers sitting on
them for a story that turned out to be a
complete fraud it came from the bowels
of the U.S Security State and so the
media it's it's the same thing as right
before the 2020 election the entire
media United to say that the uh
documents from which the reporting was
done based on the hunter Biden laptop
was Russian disinformation everyone in
the world knows now that this is a lie
every media outlet with Biden safely
elected was able to verify the
authenticity of those documents there's
no question about the provenance of
those documents those came from Hunter
Biden's laptop Rush had nothing to do
with it and not a single media Outlet
not one that spread those lies this is
Russian disinformation over and over in
the days and weeks before people went to
vote went back and retracted it
apologized for it let alone acknowledge
the scope of that Scandal so how can the
media active participants in the
russiagate fraud possibly
do anything other than try and bury and
obscure the fact that this happened it's
like asking bank robbers who plan the
bank robbery and then went and implement
it to expose it to the world and talk
about how how threatening it was of
course they're not going to do that
they're doing the opposite and that to
me is the most dangerous aspect of this
is in the minds of American Elites
including the ones who work at the
largest media corporations in their
minds and they really do believe this
the fact that Donald Trump to them is a
hitler-like figure who is an existential
threat to all things decent in American
democracy means that everything and
anything they do is justifiable morally
including lying including censoring they
including abandoning the journalistic
cause that has that's an explicit
mindset that they have I want to stay on
this but I want to say what Rachel
Maddow said about you this is what
Rachel Maddow from MSNBC said about you
this quite a while ago hang on a second
describing you during your salon tenure
the American
left's most Fearless political
commentator again for somebody watching
this they're going to say well this
guy's a pro-trump guy he's a republican
he's a conservative he's probably
hardcore this again let me say this
folks Rachel Maddow if you know who she
is MSNBC
the American lefts most Fearless
political commentator so you're saying
what Obama did to go after Trump is is
way worse than Obama gave what they did
right when the Watergate here's a
question for you for the audience maybe
that doesn't closely follow everything
in opinions that you have what do you
think about President Donald Trump
I think if you look at
I think Donald Trump is probably the
most transformational political figure
in the last let's say
six or seven decades of American
political life maybe you can compare it
to Ronald Reagan in terms of the
transformational effect and to uh FDR
um I just mean that neutrally
transformational can be good or for bad
sure what what if and it was so that's
what fascinated me so much about that
presidential debate without Trump is you
kind of got a glimpse a reminder of what
the Republican party was prior to Donald
Trump this kind of tired stale uh Elite
serving Orthodoxy that that's why all
these people are three they're all very
smart people they all have on paper the
perfect record to run for president and
in their own party nobody likes them
they have three because they espouse an
ideology the Republican party in 2009
believed in and in 2013 believed in and
now in 2023 don't believe in it all and
that's because Donald Trump gave them
that space to start to understand why
that ideology was so misguided against
their interest unpacked it please so I I
don't want it first of all I want to say
that if you go back and look what what
Trump did is not go into a party and
completely change a party on his own the
signs were there the signs to me first
started appearing with the ability of
Ron Paul
to run a presidential campaign in 2008
and 2012. Ron Paul probably to me is the
single most honest politician
in in a long time someone of that
stature meaning just he says what he
believes and won't change a word of it
for political game he went into places
like Iowa and South Carolina the reddest
District within those states with a
message that was heretical for
Republican Party politics which was
the war in Iraq was a moral mistake that
we shouldn't have military bases all
over the world dominating the world
through military force is something that
is not in your interest it's serving the
interest of a tiny Elite these are
people who are you know kind of bred on
the idea that the war on terror and the
the war in Iraq were the most patriotic
things possible and he found this huge
uh part of the Republican electorate for
which those sorts of things resonated
and it wasn't only that he had a lot of
other kind of you know anti-orthodox
views on economic policy as well that
obviously there was a sense that he was
tapping into which made his presidential
campaign infinitely more successful than
people thought I think he came in second
in the Iowa caucus if I remember
correctly in 2008
um or 2012 and so the stirrings were
already there that there was this kind
of pop and neocons as well before Trump
started seeing it as well they were
already planning to to back Hillary
Clinton knowing that the best vessel for
a neoconservative foreign policy was
Hillary Clinton and not whoever the
Republican party was about to nominate
well before Trump ever happened
Trump saw that he understood that he
gave voice to it and he did two things
one is because he's such a talented just
kind of Communicator right like a
communicator to the ordinary person it's
what he's been doing his whole life he
was a TV star I remember you know when I
lived in in New York in the 90s he
prided himself on the fact that his Fame
came not from the Manhattan Elite but
from sort of the construction workers
who built his buildings that was always
something he prided himself on he had
that kind of Outer Borough resentment so
he's always been a great communicator
he's been able he was able to take that
message that Ron Paul who was not a
great communicator had already proven
there was a a a a a a a a base for and
expand it but then what happened as well
is once Trump started
attacking the CIA and attacking the FBI
and you know laying bare how politics
actually works he went to those debates
and I saw this I'm sure you saw that
entire middle section behind which the
the right behind the fox microphones are
reserved for the Republican National
Committee and they're big donors that's
what that section is for those who
that's the reaction you're hearing Trump
would get boot attacking Jeb Bush and
it's the best to say yeah these are all
the lobbyists this is the swamp yeah
right he gave like he shined a light on
the things you're not supposed to shine
a light on in terms of how politics
actually works and so once Republican
voters started seeing wow the CIA is
really corrupt the FBI is willing to
abuse their power these agencies the
Republican voters have long been taught
to Revere they began seeing them in a
different light and now if you want to
go into Republican politics like Nikki
Haley does or Chris Christie does or Tim
Scott or whomever or Mike Pence and say
we need to back the Pentagon on and it's
arming of Ukraine we need to go and you
know give the CAA greater authorities or
the FBI greater authorities you're going
to provoke a revulsion among Republican
voters and that's because Trump
took what had been kind of the
percolating seeds of this sentiment and
turned it into the dominant governing
Orthodoxy of the Republican party which
is why I haven't changed a single view
of mine since Rachel Maddow said that
what has changed is the nature of the
two political parties there's a reason
Bill crystal is a Democrat and other
neoconservatives are Democrats and why
Democrats overwhelmingly now Revere
those Security State agencies it's
because the Democratic party has
transformed into crazy the party of
militarism and imperialism in
corporatism and the only resistance that
you get to any of this is in the
populist Wing the populist right wing of
the Republican party that's not my fault
I didn't cause that I'm just observing
it that's pretty wild so to to think you
know by the way this happens politically
when sometimes they shift uh and you're
seeing that now more people where they
say you know I I you know I I didn't
change how I view things you change
right Bill Morris talked about a lot of
other people are talking about it but
let's go into the mug shot Rob if you
want to put the picture up so yesterday
7 30. gets rained you know he goes
through and he gets this picture of the
mug shot which I'm sure he thought about
this on how he was going to pose for the
picture yeah he probably in front of
mirror post how do I want the mug shot
to be because this by the way you have
to think about it this is going to last
in the last hundreds of years this is
permanent right when you think about
Adam send a list of the greatest mug
shots of all time Rob if you want to
pull this up yeah this is at the top now
this is there's a lot of them if you go
through these uh the the the I think
they have Bill Gates as number one if
you go on this one uh keep going down
keep going down keep going down there's
them right there you got Bill Gates you
got Frank Sinatra keep going you got
Jay-Z you got Eminem you got Nick Nolte
to the left you got Jeremy Meeks who
women went crazy over you got David
Bowie you got Keanu Reeves keep going
keep going keep going anybody else yeah
James Brown oh James Brown does not look
good Robert Downey Jr
okay Elvis is going to be on this list
no doubt yeah so when you look at this
when you're looking
MLK yeah he's got to be at the top of
the list I mean this is listen this is
marketing at its highest level remember
we went to Rogan's uh set yeah and he
had all the pictures
of famous mugshots just insert Trump's
mug shot right into the top at the top
and Glenn do you see and Pat for all you
guys look at like okay yeah his hair he
probably had a stylist there look at
that face of look at who yo who do you
think he's thinking like you know what's
going on in that head I'm going to kill
everybody I'm gonna go after like now
Pat that face and the way he spoke after
it's a spirit his first tweets since
getting suspended yeah go on Twitter and
post a picture his first it's almost as
if he wanted he wanted that mug shot
give me the mug shot this is gonna help
me get elected and the left is thinking
we're gonna destroy him with his mug
shot I wouldn't be surprised if his next
book's gonna be that much
and didn't uh Elon retweet this you see
what did he say go to Elan real quick
when he retweet it Glenn while he's
looking dude so Glenn do you think the
left is always up to something uh and
just going back really fast there's no
accountability everything that you said
was spot on about the spying and Obama
mama and Hillary no accountability so
that makes one think that the left runs
all of you know all the doj and
everything which I feel like there's one
or two Republicans in there uh he like
this this type of this this is this
their ploy to get him it's obviously not
working what is this it or do they have
something else up their sleeves for 2024
well I think
um well first of all it is interesting
the Tracy made because there have been
now people who have been taking mug
shots where they're famous and they know
it's going to be public and they smile
they try to make it like any other he
had that option I think he very
purposely wanted to convey this is not
something to laugh at this is not
something that's cute yeah this is not
something that's fun this is something
that is a grave attack not just on me
but on all of you and this requires
Defiance and anger and rage which I
think it does this is a an extraordinary
attempt to take the oppositional leader
in the United States imagine we looked
at any other country doing this yeah and
we said oh here's the person leading all
public opinion polls by far the most
likely person to challenge the current
government leading in poll in many polls
to become the next president and now
that same government is Prosecuting that
person and not for traditional crimes of
murder or kidnapping or extortion or
bribery but for crimes that require this
kind of very dubious interpretation this
pioneering use of the law so I think
that anger that he's conveying there was
the right choice because it isn't
something to be frivolous about I think
that that was
um something that he wants his
supporters to understand but yeah I
think you know
um you look at the way in which these
legal processes are being abused or and
even just the cynicism of it so the
first case was brought by a liberal
district attorney where they want to put
him on trial in Manhattan a place that
that 90 to 10 voted for Joe Biden the
this one will be into in Atlanta
presumably unless he moves it to federal
court and then there's just the Fulton
County but it's still a very Democratic
uh place and then obviously the one in
Washington as well with the January 6th
indictment under Jack Smith which is
filled with Democrats as well the only
exception is the Mar-A-Lago one that's a
little bit more balanced but they're not
even pretending that they want this to
be a fair process you know there is this
Theory and I think it's very
conspiratorial and I don't think it's
true that Democrats won against want to
run against Trump they know that these
kinds of indictments will solidify his
ability to get the nomination more
easily driving Republican voters into
his arms that's certainly the effect of
it I'm not sure that's the intent I
don't think it's the intent I think the
intent is they want blood and the reason
they want blood is because basically
Donald Trump vandalized everything they
regard as sacred about American politics
and every Power Center views it that way
liberal Democrats view it that way they
it's a bloodthirsty movement do you know
how often liberal politics now is about
very little other than
demanding the censorship of your
political enemies for the imprisonment
of your political questions
it's almost there's nothing there's no
positive policy constructive aspect to
it they want everybody silenced and
de-platform or in prison yeah and they
label you and your race once they say
you're racist that's it you're racist
it's all emotion at this point yeah like
logic is out the window being stoic is
out the window any sort of like hey this
is how things go it's people on the
right are freaking pissed because they
see what the hell is going on here and
in many cases rightfully so especially
what you highlighted with the Russia
collusion and all that and everything
you've done with the reporting people
are pissed this is why they're
coalescing around Trump and they're
basically
just anointing him at that but on the
left they just as you said they want
blood it's just an emotional trumped
Arrangement syndrome everything with
that I think the I think what I think
what began as a cynical political script
turned into a true belief on the part of
most of uh American liberalism which is
the idea that Trump really is a
hitler-like figure that his movement is
this fascist
um
white nationalist dictatorship he's
seeking to impose and if you begin with
that premise a lot of what follows then
makes sense but the way it's so
dangerous is if you look even now with
the war in Ukraine
over the last poll is 55 to 45 Americans
want no more money going to Ukraine the
only reason it's that close is because
75 75 by far the biggest demographic
group of self-identified liberal
Democrats want there to be endless and
infinite support for the Ukrainian cause
by the United States why are they
suddenly so pro-war no it's because even
there they've been feeding on this
anti-russian hatred the idea the most
cataclysmic event in the life of
American liberals was the 2016 election
where Donald Trump won and Hillary
Clinton lost it was psychologically
cataclysmic there were all sorts of
reports by psychologists about mental
health episodes and neuroses and anxiety
disorders that came from it and the
reason they want that war is because
they want to destroy Russia they're even
that's the level of kind of visceral
hatred politically on which they're
feeding that they want a war to continue
for no reason other than they want to
destroy a country for no reason other
than the fact that they blame that
country for Donald Trump's election
isn't it all just come down to
Vindication and vindictiveness whether
it's people on the left being like we
gotta get back for the Russia thing or
even this you you talked about the Lula
jair bolsonaro about you're you're
concerned about him being vindictive
which he sort of is you know that's not
the face of a uh someone who's ready to
go lightly yeah I mean did you blame him
it's a danger it's a pretty dangerous uh
political climate where people are
offering operating on their most Primal
tribal and visceral impulses and those
have been deliberately stoked and
cultivated primarily by the media for a
lot of self-interested reasons and when
you put that kind of cauldron of just
human intensity and emotion pitted one
another against the the other only bad
things can happen from them so let's
talk about the debate let's go through
the debate if you if you don't mind just
take the leading run us through what you
thought the debate was how was it who
performed you know I know you kind of
commented on Nikki Haley and vivec and
all this stuff you had Vivek on your
show right after the debate how did you
think the debate went the numbers just
to kind of give the number for people
that are watching this the numbers came
in on how many views it got debate
ratings only 12.8 million people watched
it 13 million less than Donald Trump's
debut in 2015 of many will say a big
part of that is because
Trump and Tucker took a lot of views
away when they did that Twitter X show
together Taco Rex show together but what
was your feeling about the debate we
were right next to each other so we saw
the same thing yeah so if you look at
all the punditry heading into that
debate the conventional assertion was
that everybody was going to attack
Governor DeSantis for the obvious reason
that he's been depicted and held up
forever as the only alternative to Trump
so if you're looking to move up in the
polls and you believe the notion that
DeSantis is the real viable alternative
to Trump you obviously want to take
DeSantis down in order to replace him
none of that happened I don't think the
Santas got attacked a single time not
one person attacked he was essentially
ignored he did a perfectly fine job he's
very I think he's a very skilled speaker
he has a good message all of that
somehow when you put it all together the
sum is less than its parts but I found
it so notable that all of the attention
instead got devoted to Vivek oh yeah why
why did they all go up there and decide
to attack vivec
part of it I think is a genuine
resentment let's like imagine you know
you spent your career you're like the
governor you've got elected to the
Senate you're you're the ambassador to
the U.N you're the vice president of the
United States and that and some guy
comes along that four months ago no
American no one knew who he was he's
incredibly
self-confident let's like just use the
the positive sense of that term you can
call him kind of arrogant he probably
comes off that way to people who dislike
him his enormous amount of self-belief
and he's ahead of them all in the polls
that's why he was in that Center
position right next to the Santa's ball
Nikki Haley and you know Tim Scott
the defenses like yeah so a lot of it is
obviously just like genuine personal
resentment in Anger like there was
toward Trump and they also have no
relationship with him whatsoever exactly
which is like he's new on the scene and
and and and for that reason he has no
truck he has no interest in carrying any
kind of personal favor he loved the fact
that they were attacking him but I don't
think it's just that these are very
professional politicians they spend a
lot of money on Consultants they're
looking to go up onto that stage and
perform strategically they're not just
there to vent whoever you know whatever
negative emotions they have obviously
there are things going on in inside the
polls we see them a little bit publicly
but in internally and I've definitely
heard this from lots of different people
connected to various different campaigns
is that he is rising in the ways that
matter much more precipitously than even
his evident invisible in these polls in
the sense that people who are more
politically engaged are starting to like
him which is one of the key metrics
because that then filters down to the
people who are less engaged they see him
obviously as a greater threat to be the
alternative to Trump than they even see
Governor DeSantis as being and that is
amazing and I think that what that shows
is the transformational aspect we were
talking about with Donald Trump by far
the person most closely aligned with
Donald Trump ideologically is vivec and
DeSantis is trying he I mean he DeSantis
understands that there's no way to get
that nomination if he's going to
alienate the ideology that Trump has
made the predominant ideology in the
Republican party but vivec is not even
diluting it at all so the fact that the
only people who Republican voters seem
to be willing to consider are the ones
standing up and saying I am an American
First America First populist nationalist
um and all of that that comes with that
I'm gonna wage a war on the CIA and the
FBI I want to defund the FBI the FBI
want to deconstruct the permanent
administratives in Republican politics
10 years ago that would have gotten you
destroyed if you had uttered that
unintentionally now the only way to
succeed is by making it a centerpiece of
your Campaign which he has done and the
fact that kind of the one that even is
most closely aligned with Trump
ideologically is clearly starting to
become the alternative to Trump shows
how dominant that Trump ideology is
within Republican Party politics doesn't
it come down to essentially what Pat's
been talking about for months and months
and months now is that the establishment
versus the anti-establishment like just
to give a metaphor I just thought of
this let's say there was a debate but it
was all the Legacy Media guys right you
got Anderson Cooper there you got Brett
Bear there you've got David Muir you've
just got Lester Holt typical Legacy
Media right all of a sudden Center Stage
is Patrick Bet David host of the top
rated BBD podcast and they're like who
the hell is this guy they're going after
some tall skinny brown guy whatever with
a weird last name not exactly yeah David
but they're all like who the [__] and
he's winning because he's telling it
like it is he's not exactly an
establishment and he's just giving it to
you raw and real and that's essentially
what Vivek is doing that that is the key
I I've heard you say this before I
completely agree with you even like that
Rachel Maddow quote about you know my
being the the left whatever
left and right I'm not saying it doesn't
matter it does matter there's still
issues where it's a reliable indicator
of where somebody Falls but the by far
the more important metric is do you
regard American establishment
institutions of authority as
fundamentally trustworthy reliable and
benevolent or do you see them as
deceitful
malignant and entities that need to be
destroyed that anti-pro establishment
dichotomy is by far the most important
political framework for understanding
where someone's politics is and both
vivec and Trump are clearly on the
anti-establishment side of that and I
don't think any of the other candidates
on that stage including Governor
DeSantis even though he makes gestures
towards it because he has to is not
really a credible anti-establishment
figure and I think the Republican
polling is starting to reflect that it's
the same reason why Bernie was a fan
favorite of even people on the right in
2016 because he was not establishment if
the public destruction
and why millions and millions of
Americans twice voted for President
Obama and then voted for Donald Trump
which makes no sense if you see the
world through a left right prism
obviously but makes complete sense if
you see it through an anti-establishment
versus because Obama's appeal fraudulent
though it was was I'm the skinny guy
with this weird last name who hasn't
been in Washington and has no and I'm
not a bush
his appeal right no he was it was
fraudulent of course that was but at
least he had a a credible claim to
present himself that as that and you go
back to Obama's 2008 campaign and it was
all about we're going to radically
change Washington so Glenn break it all
down if it's if it's the the Obama
change narrative it's the Bernie oh the
Millionaires and billionaires if it's
the Trump it's the Vivek
all that put together where is America
at where is the American populist
movement at because there's stuff on the
left there's stuff on the right people
are just angry at what the hell's going
on with the establishment what what is
it what's the common denominator well
there was that Time magazine article
um that I'm sure you guys have seen that
was very long and unintentionally
revealing that essentially said that
there was the most extraordinary uh
unified campaign on the part of
establishment power centers to unite and
coalesce in every single way imaginable
to ensure that Biden beat Trump in 2020
and obviously the entire media was
against Donald Trump he had every
anti-incumbent obstacle starting with
covid in the way that it destroyed
businesses and shut down the United
States
um and he still came extremely close to
winning even by the certified results
right like even if you take the
certified results at its face value he
was you know 44 000 votes away from
changing three states and that shows you
two things one establishment power
centers still do have a lot of power
there are still a lot of people who
trust the media even though it's far
less than it was even 10 years ago but
when you add on to that the financial
power of Wall Street that back abiding
overwhelmingly Silicon Valley that did
the same
um they still wield a lot of power which
is why they're The Establishment and
that's how they kind of pushed an adult
Joe Biden over the Finish Line barely
though
um and I think the reason why all these
prosecutions are happening is because
nobody is confident that Joe Biden is
going to beat Donald Trump how can you
yeah so so let's let's look at this here
because I wanted to see what everybody
was going to say who the winner was
Trump said Vivek was the winner of the
debate for obvious reasons the hill said
Glenn Junkin which is kind of
interesting for them to say Glenn yonkin
would you know the hey let's go get
Glenn and Murdoch wants to go fund him
from the No Labels situation the
guardian said Trump said the santis was
the winner was the sentence as the
winner
if if we're looking at you know with
everything that's going on today you
think he's going to show up to the next
debate September 27th and at the Ronald
Reagan Library you think Trump's going
to show up to that one we think he still
doesn't have a reason to show up I think
it's going to depend on how the Paul you
know to see if anyone actually gets a
real Boost from this debate if DeSantis
start I mean that I think there was a
538 poll that quickly pulled who was the
winner 29 said to Santa's 28 percent
said vivec there was that focus group
assembled when CNN gets those like
regular people it's like you know kind
of people going on like some sort of
Excursion to go on a field trip to look
at how the Ordinary People live and they
talk to them Vivek was the winner of
that focus group I think 11 votes got uh
forever back in I think seven or
something for Haley so I think it's
going to depend I mean if Trump
continues to maintain a 45 to 50 point
lead notwithstanding the fact that he's
not showing up my guess is he'll
continue to not show up why would he
show up
um on the other hand Trump likes that
kind of debate he does he's he's
extremely good at it
um and it's possible he'll do one or two
just to do them
um but I just don't see anything
happening at that debate that changes
the fundamentals of the race I think all
it's going to do is give back a much
bigger boost
um than probably anybody else uh if you
look at the pulling uh Republicans like
the Santos it's not like they hate
DeSantis they like DeSantis primarily
because of the credit they give him for
kovid and opening up Florida but they're
just not going to abandon Trump for
anybody can I show you this poll yeah
since since you're brought up DeSantis I
mean look Trump has only risen in the
last six months right he went from 50 to
essentially 60. look at where DeSantis
was this is an earlier this year
February neck and neck with Trump dude
he's about to go below ramaswamy he's at
14 vivex at ten percent
to say that it's a disaster what's going
on in the in the DeSantis campaign would
be an understatement he was neck and
neck and now that's happening that's why
you're the expert I think clearly it's
been a failed marketing I think one of
them is that the the the Maga the fan
base the Trump supporters they're
they're literally pissed off like the
majority of us are and they're like you
know what it's Vengeance time and it's
payback and he deserves it because at
the end of the day God I was thinking
about uh thinking about you because I
was talking about Tom Ellsworth who's
who's under the weather we were talking
about sometimes God picks people to step
up
and sometimes people answer the call
some people don't you were called upon
to wake up the world and you risk
everything as I mentioned earlier Trump
did as well he risked it all he didn't
need to he's a billionaire he could sit
on in the middle he could be on a yacht
for the rest of his life he picked it
the fan the real supporters the real
people behind Trump are like you know
what look at all the [__] that came out
he was cheated like through the entire
time nobody's gonna be held accountable
we want him back in and we want him to
serve these four years and go after
everybody that's why I think and like
you said I like the Santas he's cool
he's one Pat the whole team moved here I
moved here because obviously Pat and
then great guy would like to hang out
with that that's fine I'll have a beer
with him but that's just showing you
that decline as the the people
especially with all the indictments and
all this garbage they're like no no I
want the guy that was supposed to be in
there Glenn and I want him back and I
want him to go after everything yeah I
think people are seeing that if they
don't vote for Trump if they abandon
Trump what they're essentially doing is
rewarding the maneuvering and the
scheming of the people they most hate
yes and on top of that I do think and
it's hard for me to get a sense of this
because honestly it has never mattered
to me but I know it does matter in like
some sort of political sense is the
reality is DeSantis is just not
comfortable in those sort of settings
where you're supposed to go and meet
regular people that and Trump is the
best at that and I think also that Trump
DeSantis is just kind of awkward in
those situations big time
um and I think once people kind of took
a look at that they either lost
confidence in his ability to win or they
themselves got a little bit
uncomfortable with him um you know
Trump's ability to just seem like this
kind of regular guy which again comes
from the fact that he has this Outer
Borough resentment
um despite growing up with a lot of
wealth and obviously living his whole
life as a billionaire he just always
maintained this that same I mean Richard
Nixon had that too actually he hated the
Eastern Elite he always felt like they
were looking down their nose at him
Trump very much has that just Santa's
doesn't he spent his you know career at
his he started off his life at Harvard
and Yale
um that he was in the house he had a
very kind of pro-establishment voting
record while in the house
um and so I think people the more they
kind of get a sense for him they do like
him but they're just like I said the sum
is somehow Less on the parts it just
doesn't all add up into something that
is exciting anybody and I think that's a
big part of that drop exactly can you go
to that poll real quick yeah and the
fact that Glenn that Trump his
personality that type of stage presence
now that's why people are resonating
with vivec because if you saw the
sentence it was the same thing it was
the the everything was written Vivek is
out there talking trash and that energy
Trump opened up the rooftop now people
are like we want that we don't want that
that's wrapped you know any any and he
looked like reasonably uncringy doing
exactly and you know I sat next to him
like you know as close as we're sitting
he looks you in the eye he like has this
also I don't know if you've seen but
like he has a wife and kids uh those
kids are insanely adorable his wife is
very Charming like the whole thing just
comes together and the way he speaks to
you he looked you right in the eye he's
very comfortable on his own skin people
really sense that that's like an
authenticity that can't really be
trained or or taught he's got that skill
but it's just unfortunately he's a
skinny brown kid with a weird last name
and it's just not going to happen well
not this year not this year but but his
future looks right yeah how much do you
put into these National polls especially
from 538 so if you just look at the
popularity or unpopularity or favorable
ratings for Biden and Trump pretty
similar so the disapprove is what Rob
punching on that 53 yep and a proof is
41. so the so the net disapproval rating
is 12 right so and if you go to Trump I
think it's it's bad too it's even I mean
it gets worse go to that so it's 53 so
it's 12. Rob if you scroll down you can
probably find the uh the Trump or just
go to the top I'm not a big pull Liker
anyway it's very similar to Trump I
think Trump is actually even worse
Rob if you just go to the top buddy
you'll find the uh there it is
there it is to the to the right Trump so
all right so just go to the very end
yeah all right so it's what 17 I don't
believe that pulled so 56 30 point is
this there's about a 16 it's like an
aggregation a poll yeah exactly how much
stock do you put into this because
ultimately what this is telling me is
just like I've said before October of
2024 it's gonna be like breaking news
neck and neck Biden Trump it's gonna be
anybody's race you know it's going to
come down to 50 000 votes in you know
Fulton County and in Pennsylvania and in
certain parts of Detroit what have you
where does this break and how much do
you put in stock into these polls well I
mean the 20 in it was very similar in
2016 I mean Trump and and Hillary in
this kind of question were two of the
most unpopular political figures to run
for the presidency in the modern era and
yet Trump ended up winning by a pretty
comfortable margin in terms of the
Electoral College and the way that the
states broke down obviously not in the
popular vote
um so a lot of this
matters in a in a very kind of limited
sense who cares if 90 of people in
California and uh and and uh and New
York hate hate Trump
um he's going to lose those States and
it doesn't matter by what margin also if
you have two unpopular candidates at the
end of the day people are going to want
to know when did that how did my life
what was my life better under one or the
other and it is just the case that prior
to covid the Trump economy was doing
extremely well the other issue is Trump
was the first American President in
decades not to involve the U.S in a new
War I know people don't want to hear
that I know people but that is an
amazing uh fact to me that there has you
you have to go back I mean not even
Jimmy Carter you have to like have a
very broad definition in order to find
one no new Wars under Donald Trump
um and the economy was doing very
everyone I think at the end of the day
that's what people care about the most
and that's what they should care about
the most is their own self-interest and
which of these presidents are going to
make their lives better and I think you
know they don't have to like Trump they
have to like how the country was and how
their lives were under a trumpet imagine
a very specific question as uh sincere
Rachel maddow's uh most right Fearless
political commentator from the left why
wouldn't you vote for Trump in 2024
I mean I just don't vote because I don't
like attaching myself to a particular
candidate because I feel like it clouds
my ability to do my job as being a
journalist
um I think it's important it's a kind of
old traditional way of looking at things
but I think for me it matters like I
think once you vote for a candidate you
feel a responsibility to vindicate that
even subconsciously you know I live in
Brazil as well I look that distance that
I can maintain you know not just
Geographic but just kind of like
emotional and psychological I think it's
a very important one to maintain my
Independence when's the last time you
voted haven't voted since I became a
journalist for exactly do you think most
journalists should just not vote and sit
these things out and just be a
journalist I mean I I think what most
journalists should do is maintain a
spirit of Independence and like whether
these people vote or not because of that
old they're obviously Democrats and what
amazes me is that there used to be a
requirement that they pretend more now
you they don't pretend anymore I don't
mean the op-ed page people I mean like
the actual reporters sit on Twitter all
day explicitly endorsing Democratic
National Committee talking points in a
way that surprises me because it seems
like these media Outlets have an
interest in in maintaining that
fraudulent appearance of neutrality
they've given up on that um that doesn't
even exist anymore so I think more
important than whether you vote is
whether you work in all ways to maintain
that kind of sense of Independence let's
transition let's transition into a
couple of the topics so both vivec and
RFK have said they'll pardon Julian
Assange or pardon Snowden and that's
resonating with an audience even Elon
Musk I think did a poll should Assange
and Snowden be pardoned I think he did
that last year I don't know the exact
results on how many what the numbers
were Rob if you've seen the poll that uh
musk did there you go 80 and a half
percent 3.3 million votes 80 and a half
percent said yes 19 and a half percent
said no
do you think they should pardon them and
two do you think that's really a big
deal uh uh if one of those candidates
does that
I think it would have been I think I
think it was is incredibly disappointing
to me personally that Trump didn't
um he got way closer to pardoning
Snowden than Assange
um I thought it was a huge failure on
the part of trump not to do it the
reason he didn't do it and this is what
the second impeachment was about without
question like why were they impeaching a
president gaze away from leaving the
White House the reason was because
Republican senators were hanging over
Trump's head there were several things
they were fearful that he would do one
was declassify a bunch of old CIA files
including the JFK assassination the
other was pardoning Snowden Assange and
Mitch McConnell and Marco Rubio and a
bunch of them made very clear that if
Trump did any of that they were going to
vote to impeach him which would have
rendered him ineligible and or rather to
convict him and this that second
impeachment trial was about keeping
Trump under control on his way out I was
extremely involved in the effort to try
and get a part in for bold I knew how
close he was to Snowden I knew he wanted
to do it and I believe that's the reason
he didn't that doesn't exonerate Trump
for me but it um I think explains it but
the the I don't think there's a huge
this is not a huge issue for the
majority of Voters what symbolically
that would do though what is to say we
are not going to allow the secret part
of the government to continue to commit
crimes and to continue to hide the most
important things they're doing from the
public we're not supposed to have a part
of the government that operates in
secret we're the only people who get
punished are the ones who reveal the
crimes and the people who commit the
crimes are the ones who get shielded
these two cases are different Snowden
was somebody who actually worked inside
the government he had an oath to
maintain the secrecy of the documents he
ended up revealing Julian Assange is not
even an American citizen he has no
obligations of the U.S government of any
kind he didn't take any secrets he was
in the role of journalists he did
something the New York Times times in
the Washington Post do every day which
is he got secrets from someone who
worked inside the government which is
Chelsea Manning and he published them
and the the fear of the Obama
Administration they wanted to prosecute
Assange was that how do we justify
Prosecuting Assange while we don't
prosecute the editors of the New York
Times and the guardian that worked with
him to publish exactly the same
documents the case and the problem with
the Assange prosecution aside from the
fact that it's a huge travesty in terms
of press freedom is that the United
States has no ability to go around the
world and give its lectures about press
freedom in Russia and Iran in North
Korea and anywhere you go to any of
those countries as an American
journalists and you say why is it that
you're imprisoning journalists who are
dissidents in your country who criticize
your government they will immediately
say are you kidding who are you to give
us that lecture you have arguably the
most Innovative and important journalist
of his generation sitting in a prison
cell going on a decade now if you count
the Asylum he needed from Ecuador who
has done nothing wrong other than reveal
war crimes on the part of the United
States government so more important than
the personal outcome of these two people
in Snowden has an okay life in Russia
he's you know doing well he has a uh an
American Wife who was his girlfriend
from way before he became Edward Snowden
they have two small children they have a
beautiful family he's doing well
economically he can't leave Russia but
he's free within Russia Assange is in a
prison cell in a high security prison
cell
so beyond the kind of personal stake
which I care about a lot because they're
both my friends and pull people I admire
a lot is the symbolic importance of
saying the U.S security state is not
going to continue to have the power to
destroy the lives of people who reveal
their crimes that really is ultimately
what it's about it would be an act of
incredible courage for a president to
stand up to the U.S Security State and
say we know you want these people
destroyed and we're going to Pardon them
and that's going to show that
transparency is now the new rule of how
you're going to function so do you think
pagosian was killed by Putin
I don't know for sure
80 20 70 30 yes 70 30 yes 70 30 yes
perfect so 70 30 yes if if the number
with Putin is 12 you know I think he's
at 11 or 12 kill list whatever he's got
the people he's taking out and couple
them uh jumped off buildings pretty
intense
billionaires just killing themselves you
know so one of them at a party in India
or something like that right so when you
think about some of these things with
him and
for Ace the average skeptical person
who's paranoid would would I think it'd
be a fair question to ask knowing how
Putin is
and for Snowden to live in Russia
feeling safe why would he be safe does
Putin follow the guidance of
whistleblower protection whatever
whatever or is he keeping him safe
because Snowden is giving him
information you know these are these are
very honest questions that some people
are wondering why is Snowden safe in
Russia led by a guy like Putin so let me
let me explain this so first of all the
idea that Snowden would give information
that would help another country surveil
on its citizens in order to be kept out
of prison
or worse is inconsistent with everything
that Snowden did in his life when we
were working with Snowden in Hong Kong
we I would say the percentage chance
that we assigned to the fact that at the
end of that process he was going to end
up in American custody in an orange
jumpsuit and we were never going to hear
from him again because he would be
disappeared to a super max prison for
the next 40 years we had a probability
of 90 to 95 percent that was it it was a
miracle that he escaped the clutches of
the American government that happened
through a series of very improbable acts
so Snowden already proved he would be
willing to go to prison give up his
Liberty for the rest of his life in
order to make it much more difficult for
states to surveil having shown that he's
willing to go to prison
to prevent surveillance why would he
then turn around weeks later and make
the exact opposite calculation that I'm
willing to help the Russians surveil in
order to stay out of prison that makes
no sense but that's the first that's the
first thing the second thing is
when there was a time you know and I
know this is this is a long ago history
but when when Snowden Snowden picked
Hong Kong because it was kind of a city
of resistance to him of resistance to
Chinese tyranny but it was also a place
he knew that the US government would
have a hard time getting us so it was
kind of a p he put a lot of thought into
the the place that he wanted us to to
work with him and at the time people
were saying he was a Chinese spy because
he had gone to Hong Kong
when he ended up leaving Hong Kong his
intention was to go to South America
where he was getting Asylum either in
Bolivia and Ecuador he was going to fly
through Moscow on his way to Havana and
then on to South on to Latin America and
the the bite Administration or rather
the bomb Administration and they boast
about this bullied the Cubans and said
if you want a deal to get rid of that
embargo no chance if you allow Snowden
safe Passage through which they had
already given him they withdrew that
safe passage and that's why he got
trapped in the Moscow airport he spent
48 days trapped in the Moscow airport in
this International Zone before they
would let him into Moscow and the whole
time I was certain that the U.S would be
able to offer the Russians whatever they
wanted because they were desperate to
get their hands on Snowden I don't know
if you remember but they thought that he
was on the plane of the Bolivian
president Eva Morales they had a hunch
when he was coming back from Russia they
forced down the plane of a sovereign
president Eva Morales on the hunch that
he had Snowden on that plane with him
when he was coming back that's how badly
they wanted Snowden so I thought okay
they're going to offer the Russians he
we have you know 12 Russian prisoners
that you want back we're willing to give
them to you we're willing to make this
concession that concession I thought for
sure that was going to happen and it
didn't happen I went to Moscow the next
year I met with Snowden I did a panel
um with some Russian media and Russian
government officials and I asked that I
was asking everybody that why couldn't
that deal be reached why didn't they
make a deal for Snowden and what they
told me were a few things number one the
US and the Russian political class hate
each other so much going back for
decades that they would rather
you know avoid deals in their interest
then make deals in their interest but
the real reason is is that Putin could
not give Snowden back to the U.S it
would be considered a deeply unrussian
thing to do because one of Russia's kind
of national attributes is they have
always been a refuge for dissidents from
the West you know you do something
against the West you get refuge in in
Russia that's something that's crucial
politically to Russians to their sense
of of their identity and there was just
no way Putin politically I know he's
considered a totalitarian he's not a
totalitarian in the sense of you know
North Korea or Saudi Arabia he answers
to political classes there are
dissidents in Russia there are
oppositional parties and it was just too
it's just too contrary to how Russia
functions and operates finally Snowden
wasn't traveling with the archive he
knew not to travel internationally with
the archive he not only didn't have the
archive but the passwords that he had
were Scott around the world he because
he wanted to avoid even if someone tried
to torture him being able to give access
to that information because he had
already proven he was willing to have
the worst possible outcome happen to him
rather than give up information why are
you skeptical of that I'm I don't know I
so so for me okay so let's just say my
daughter
uh is 22 years old okay
and one of my guys I've known who is 40
years old okay who is a full-blown
Playboy okay and my daughter says Dad
it's I'm not he's just a friend you know
and I'm like baby I trust you I don't
trust him uh-huh he's going to flirt
with you and he's very good at getting
you to flip and you know fall in love
with them for a night or whatever let's
just say that guy's not a friend he's a
colleague but I know who his DNA is
right okay even worse if he's not an
ally and he's an enemy and he wants to
find a way to do something to you and
he's going to figure out any ways to go
do that to you okay
in this situation
um okay I let's just say I trust Snowden
I don't trust Putin and and if we were
to give an acid if America Joe Biden you
know got Brittany Greiner for Victor
what's his last name bout or you know
Victor you know however we say his last
name killer right you mean to tell me uh
a uh Putin couldn't have said you give
me Victor I'll give you Snowden yeah I
mean Victor's pretty powerful dude why
didn't that happen they had snowed in
their clutches in that International
Airport why didn't they reach a deal
with the the Americans I'll tell you in
my opinion give us everything and we'll
give you Snowden but I'll tell you why I
wouldn't do it if you're Putin
Snowden is way more powerful to have
than Victor bout so in your in it's like
saying hey let's trade cards I'll give
you a Mickey Mantle rookie card for
freaking you know John cangelosi rookie
card you're gonna say who the hell is
John cangelosi I'm gonna say well go
look him up he was a second baseman who
was 2 30 or whatever he was right okay
uh so yeah you're not going to give
Mickey for John cangelosi this is Mickey
Mantle Snowden you need Snowden you meet
because of his secrets are you kidding
me yeah okay so let me ask you this so
this is your world I wanna I wanna know
your art because you're the right guy to
talk about no absolutely I know certain
extremely well what so why do we know
the name of Edward Stone and why do
people around the world consider what
Snowden did to be heroic the reason is
is because what he did was extremely
likely to result in the imprisonment for
the rest of his life at the age of 29.
not very many people nobody killed or
death or death exactly life 100 just
like you the the best case scenario
right they were threatening to imprison
me and Laura poitrus the reporter with
whom I was working so imagine what they
would have done to Snowden they the sky
was the limit look at what they're doing
to Julian Assange Snowden knew that
Snowden took that risk when I when I
first talked to Snowden I said to him
look
I didn't know how much he knew I didn't
know how sophisticated was I didn't know
his age but I you know I felt like it
was my responsibility as a journalist
thinking maybe I'm dealing with somebody
with mental health issues
with some kind of skewed Vision I made
very clear to him I said look you're
committing multiple serious felonies
this is the greatest National Security
league in the history of the United
States
you understand you're almost definitely
going to end up in an American prison
and not a nice American prison for the
rest of your life he said that's the
risk I've already I've already decided
that I'm willing to take so already
Snowden is somebody operating with a
completely different moral framework
than the vast majority of people
including most of us I'm not somebody
who's saying I'm willing to I mean I did
take risks but my risk wasn't anywhere
near the risk that Snowden took I had I
was the world the journalist had first
amendment protections lots of other
different considerations so he had just
proven he's willing to go to prison for
the rest of his life
in pursuit of this cause this cause
being preventing the internet from
becoming this zone of mass surveillance
why a month later
Putin comes to him or whoever the FSB
comes to him and says you give us this
information or we're removing that
Asylum and we're going to let the
Americans take you to prison why does he
then a month later make exactly the
opposite moral calculation and say you
know what actually I don't want to go to
prison enough to give you this
information I'd rather give you this
information and avoid prison he just
proved he was willing to go to prison
for the rest of his life in order not to
in order to not help a state for be able
to further surveil so this idea that he
would have helped he would have given
this information to Putin to stay out of
an American prison or a Russian prison
is totally again the fact that he didn't
end up in American prison
was the biggest flu possible the
government of Hong Kong stuck its middle
finger up in the United States when the
United States demanded that he not be
able to to leave for its own reasons
Snowden had proven that the US was
spying on Hong Kong his moral framework
the one under which he was operating the
reason it's heroic is because it's so
radically different I don't know we
rationally so so why would we why would
the United States government's threat
not deter Snowden from leaking that
information but the Russian government's
threats would make him give up
information to help the Russians spy
better on their own because Russians
didn't destroy his life America American
government did because Russia didn't
destroy his life America did so so to me
look I'm just a naturally curious guy
that's asking yeah
that's the uh you know you're the expert
in this you you're the one that knows
more about this than anybody else
because you were the guy that broke the
story so I'm talking to the story yeah
no for me I think it's a healthy level
of skepticism to have with that by the
way I I am thankful for snow and I'm
thankful for what he did I'm grateful
for what he did and levels that words
can't even describe God knows what he
did he ruins his life many would say at
29 years old there's a level of
patriotism that goes with that but it's
complicated as well right you always
it's always the Whistleblower from the
other side you hate you know you always
like The Whistleblower from your side
right that's right right so it's easy to
be like well you know can't believe what
he's doing and he saw everybody on the
media this is not something he should be
doing if you love America you should not
be supporting what's snowden's I don't
know if you remember that a CNN what's
in it and everybody was saying of course
yeah
all I'm saying is why is he there uh
with a Putin's Camp approach and say for
the rest of your life you're protected
as if you're a president we're going to
give you that kind of protection for the
rest of your life and if you're not
going to give us any intel that's
already public maybe teach us mechanisms
on how they were investigating on the
people for us to know how to investigate
and maybe his moral compass doesn't hurt
him to say well I'm not really doing
anything I'm just going to show you how
they did it and then you do whatever you
want to do with it but this is how the
government was investigating on its
people maybe that's something where he's
like I don't feel bad about doing
something like this I don't know I I
totally get the skepticism in from the
distance I'd likely have the same um you
know questions the the issue of course
is I can't prove the negative right
totally so I can't move to you snowed in
didn't do it all I can tell you is I
have you know I spent a lot of time like
very intense immersive time with Snowden
in all of those days we were in Hong
Kong doing this work I've maintained a
very close friendship with him since I
talked to him you know with a great
amount of regularity
um and you know that's not a
particularly persuasive thing to say
take my word for it I understand it's
not an ethical code I think the only
thing I can ask people to do is look at
the actual evidence of what his conduct
has been and the other thing is there is
that Russian code that I know that I
didn't understand until I went and
talked to a bunch of people but if you
look at the Cold War Whenever there were
people who felt persecuted by Western
governments or who became spies they
always were given refuge in Russia from
the West for as long as they wanted to
until the day that they died it's it's
it's it's it's a part of the Russian
moral code I talked to the head of RT
um on whom I was uh uh with a panel and
I asked her that question I interrogated
her about that because I I genuinely
didn't understand stand by the U.S and
Russia didn't reach a deal to turn
Snowden over and that was what she was
trying to get me to understand was it
would be a very unrussian thing to do to
take a political dissident who wants
refuge in Russia and turn them over to
the United States I it's it's not
something that you can understand if
that's not part of the code you ever
been to cross stations in Beverly Hills
the restaurant probably not okay uh
would love to take you it's incredible
unbelievable food they have two kitchens
there one of them is the kitchen for the
on family okay the recipes that they've
created like their garlic noodles which
when you eat you age backwards
[Laughter]
the other kitchen is for the average
people to go on people like you and I if
we work there you cannot go in the
kitchen
unless if you're parted on family okay
so what does this mean yeah I mean I'm
sure Russia is thankful for it but
listen you ain't Russian bro you know
what I'm saying you're snowing yeah
there's a there's a level of skepticism
I think a president or any prime
minister would have for anyone that's a
whistleblower because in the back of the
mind of that Prime Minister President is
this guy's a whistleblower you know what
I'm saying I mean great job for what you
did but [__] you could whistleblow on
anybody because so we got to be also
protective of your abilities to
whistleblow I don't know if you
understand like like if I'm
communicating my thoughts properly or
not
they don't trust them yeah I mean you
know that that's an interesting point
like you know how a guy that like you
know a guy that says something like this
okay he'll say look just between us
okay just between us and then you test
them three times and you leak him in
formation inaccurate information and
then he tells three other people guess
what he just did he just validated to
you he can't keep information and it's
not hard to test stuff like this with
people it's very easy if if I do it on a
small level with a company or a sales
organization or family or friends like
any time I wanted to know which one of
my friends that I went to high school
with I just would talk to them I would
tell them certain private things and I
would say just please keep it between us
if I got three people that called me I
already know who that guy was right okay
so either I intentionally leak in
formation that I want to be leaked or I
just realize you can't fully trust that
person you cannot no and and that that
that's interesting you know when first
of all I think the starting point for
all of this discussion should always be
why is it that Edward Snowden
having not only leaked information but
done so in the most responsible way
right like he he could have sold the
information to a foreign government and
gotten millions and millions of dollars
that archive was extremely valuable he
could have dumped it all over the
internet instead he came to us and when
he came to us he was adamant that we
agreed to conditions that I even found
repressive about how he didn't want any
information published that could ever
even potentially put a single person In
Harm's Way he was a very conservative
whistleblower he was he imposed on us a
lot of restrictions about things that I
thought we should have been able to
publish that he didn't want published
there were things the New York Times
ended up publishing from that archive
that he was indignant about that he
thought should never been published
about how we spy on China
so he was somebody who did this in the
most responsible way possible didn't
dump it on the internet didn't sell it
to a foreign adversary came to
journalists asked us to curate it in a
very responsible way which we did there
was no suggestion that anything we ever
published harmed anybody put anybody In
Harm's Way the question the first
question should be why is somebody like
that forced to live their life in Exile
in Russia because the minute they come
back to the United States they're going
to be put in prison for the rest of the
right having said that I understand your
question again I can't prove the
negative I guess what I all I can tell
you is that
um even the information that Snowden
would have to give Snowden was not the
deputy director of the NSA Snowden was a
somewhat low-level contractor who worked
at Booz Allen what he had that was
valuable was access to the archive where
the was the documents that not so much
what Snowden had to say most of our
reporting was based on the document if
you don't have access to that archive
there's not much that Snowden can even
give you that's a value
um and he wasn't carrying with him the
archive and thumb drives with a piece of
paper that contained the password it
would have he purposely made it
extremely difficult because he didn't
want to be put in the position where
somebody could force him to turn over
that information I will tell you on this
topic and we can transition to the next
topic but I I appreciate you you know uh
uh having this exchange with me on this
topic
um this isn't about Snowden I'm not
putting this on Snowden right you're on
on Putin I'm putting this on how Putin
views an American dude you're not
priority to me you're not Russian you
you this is not your motherland you
don't love this place like I love it
Gorbachev yelts and you know that this
is like the greatest country in the
world he views that I mean Putin is it
true a Russian national a Russian
nationalist so for him he's gonna always
and by the way the the best leaders ever
are typically more paranoid and
skeptical than the average leader if if
I can come and betray you once and kind
of do it again and again and again
you're weak but if I can come and betray
you once and you still are able to
entertain a relationship but you know
there's filters that you can't go
through certain rails you know certain
things you can't enter anymore I respect
that leader and I put Putin as a
formidable leader Putin has a
lightweightness he wants to be
complimented and you can win him over
with flat he's not with you he's a true
G who he is so but I trust my enemies uh
way more than I trust my allies here's
what I mean by that I know
my competitors anytime I build any
businesses whether it's insurance or
whatever I did I knew my enemy woke up
every morning wanting to put me out of
business I respect that I knew my enemy
woke up every day wanting to make sure I
went bankrupt I respect that I'm not
upset at it I actually totally get it
you know if you play you know you're
fighting somebody in the streets guess
what the guy is going to do you have to
assume the guy that wants to beat the
living crap out of you right so that's
not a naive or Place coming from where
it's like while I'm trying to be
antagonistic no I just think this is the
enemy here's how he views it let me go
into another topic uh with this and
transition out from this Brazil your
you've lived you are you still in Brazil
or you're living yeah so Brazil I I uh I
have an affinity with Brazil I name my
daughter Ayrton Senna you know how the
View Center over there sent as a race
car driver you know 1994 all the stories
with him what he did beloved with the
day he died I don't know if you've seen
his document or if you haven't yet yes
no no I know I know emotional right I
relate to the Gown how he's wide are you
relate how he wanted to you know do what
he did with the you know Corners he was
taken and how he said you guys move the
tire that's why I crashed you guys
wouldn't they never know we never moved
the tire and he found that they moved
the tire two inches that's why he hit
the tire you know what store that is
when he went through one of the corners
no you guys screwed up and they had to
apologize to him he says because the
tires I was going on practice was not
the same you moved the two inches that
kind of a guy that's on Highway freaking
maniacal I love and how how much you
love this country
so you live in Brazil you know operation
car wash
has been documented on God knows how
much you know what he's done and you
know the 600 million dollars the one guy
that was a super billionaire and goes
from being a super billionaire to all of
a sudden losing everything and he goes
to jail and I've studied this whole
thing you know in the past and then
bolsonaro who he was and then Lula who
he was whose Lula's ties are and who how
they viewed Lula and you kind of came
and did something kind of you know you
did some kind of an interview with Lula
he came down sat down and talked to you
for about an hour and 20 minutes or
something like that
what is your impression of Lula and
bolsonara and and the reason why you
know assume uh Americans like you know
who is Lula in America is Lula a uh
Bernie Sanders is bolsonaro a trump is
Lula more than Obama or Biden is who is
Lula because there's a lot this guy went
to jail he did a lot of stuff to steal
money from the government based on stuff
that's been documented in your eyes is
Lula a good guy is he a bad guy
bolsonaro is you good guys you're a bad
guy what do you think about these two
characters
so
when first of all blue is life story you
just have to acknowledge no matter what
your ideology is is an inspirational
life story he was born into the deepest
and most extreme form of poverty in a
country where poverty means something
different than it means in the United
States he was one of nine children he
was illiterate until the age of 10.
um he got a job in a factory he lost one
of his fingers in a factory he became a
union leader so he emerged from both
poverty Union activism and then became a
hardcore political leftist he was never
really the kind of political leftist of
say Castro or Hugo Chavez in fact he
always tried to distance himself from
that he ran for president three times
Brazil came out of this dictatorship
um that was the result of the CIA
helping right-wing Generals in 1964
overthrow a democratically elected
government they impose a dictatorship
for 21 years that was brutal
and when it re-democratized in 1985
Google became a national figure he ran
for president three times lost all three
times because the perception that he was
too leftist for Brazil the elite was
aligned against him in 2002 he
understood that in order for him to win
he needed to become a more moderated
figure not just a kind of pretend
moderated figure but an actually
moderated figure he chose his vice
president this highly respected
entrepreneur and Banker who was a
billionaire or something close to it and
when he got into office he began
essentially accommodating uh the
financial Elite and the financial sector
under Brazil's first two terms from 2002
to 2010 Brazil's economic growth was
explosive it went from something like
the 15th largest economy in the world to
the sixth largest economy in the world
it surpassed the UK everybody got richer
the rich got richer he was able to take
a lot of that National wealth distribute
it to programs that gave a guaranteed
monthly payment to people who couldn't
feed their children that level of
poverty he created opportunities for
poor people to go to college for the
first time there were good things that
his government did
Brazil at the same time never got out of
the systemic corruption that was the
result of that dictatorship so the way
that you get votes is you have to pay
people off the way that you get anything
done politically is you move money
around all the Brazilian politicians
have
huge amounts of Swiss bank accounts that
have been hidden and finally discovered
and Lula and his party PT were very much
a part of that because they were running
the political system so Google himself
will tell you when I asked I've done
several interviews with him including
when he was in prison and he will tell
you that his party has always been one
of grave corruption
what happened was in
by the way he's probably the most
talented politician are you kidding me
there's no person who can move crowds
about him he says one of the best
politicians out there he when he
operates Communicator 2007 he had an 86
approval rating every time federalistic
democracy because everybody got richer
and not you know obviously a lot of that
is locked a lot of it has to do with
International commodity prices things
the president does in control but the
president gets credit when the economy
does well the economy did very well and
he left office with that kind of
popularity
when the his chosen successor who was
Doma Rousseff
um who was actually a communist gorilla
she picked up arms she uh went to prison
to fight the Brazilian the the
dictatorship when commodity crisis
prices collapsed the economy in Brazil
collapsed they saw an opportunity to get
rid of that party finally they impeached
her in 2016 and then in 2017 this
anti-corruption probe Car Wash
um the biggest anti-corruption probe in
Brazil's history one of the biggest in
the world started putting into prison
billionaires and some of the country's
most powerful politicians and I was a
supporter of it at the start like a lot
of people were
it started to become clearly politically
motivated they were aimed at certain
figures and certain parties and kind of
protecting the center-right ID the
parties with which they had an ideology
they started to become put under
suspicion in 2019 I had a source who
hacked into the phones of the leading
judges and prosecutors including the
ones who presided over Lulu's conviction
he was leading all public opinion polls
in 2017 20 points ahead of bolsonaro 25
points ahead of bolsonaro into the 2018
race they took him they put him into
prison they convicted him on these
corruption charges rendered him
ineligible bolsonaro ran without having
to get past Lula and he got elected in
2019 right at the start of the Boston
our presidency I got this gigantic
archive that proved the whole time the
judge was plotting with political actors
with the prosecutors essentially using
corrupt methods in order to fight
corruption when we exposed it it
required a nullification of Lulu's
conviction he was able to leave prison
as a result of the reporting we were
doing that's the reason why there was so
much anger and hostility toward me uh
from the bolsonaro movement because they
finally got wool in jail and are
reporting forced his release
runs for president in 2022 defeats
bolsonaro by a tiny margin same issue
with Trump the whole establishment
United against bolsonaro had all the
challenges of covid he still almost won
they had their own January 6th movement
as well their own January 6th moment
exactly because bolsonaro claimed that
his loss was due to fraud
Bolton are over the years the you know
he was his back bencher he's made a lot
he had made a lot of statements like I
don't really believe in democracy I
think Pinochet was a great guy I want to
the only thing Pinochet did wrong was he
didn't kill more Communists in the
country he made a lot of statements that
were very disturbing I viewed bolsonaro
as a real threat when he got into pres
in the presidency the entire
establishment aligned against him like
they did with Trump and began using
anti-democratic methods to defeat the
bolsonaro movement censoring imprisoning
political enemies just like they were
doing with Trump and I became an
outspoken opponent of the things that
were being done against bolsonaro and
against his movement obviously changed
Where I Stood politically suddenly the
bolsonaro movement saw me a lot more
favorably the left began to turn on me
and and view me as an enemy
bolsonaro ended up as a very weak
president Lula is a very weak president
because Brazil is run by this kind of
very corrupt Centrist class that's
transactional in nature there's not a
lot that presidents can do one of the
things I like about Lula is he's a very
outspoken defender of Julian Assange he
is you know constantly demanding the
persecution of a sun stop he refuses to
get Brazil involved in the war in
Ukraine saying we don't have a war with
Russia we have a war with poverty and
inequality and we're going to use our
resources not to feed a NATO War but to
um but to try and help Brazil if you ask
me is Lula corrupt my answer would be I
want to see a fair trial not a trial
filled with corruption there's certainly
evidence to suggest that he was part of
the systemic corruption bolsonaro though
too by the way
every one of bolsonaro's sons is a
political uh elected official they all
ran for Senate and Congress and won in
the bolstery name and they all have six
million dollar mansions and huge amounts
of personal wealth that is very
difficult to account for I think
bolsonaro and his family also have a lot
of evidence that they too are involved
in in corruption to me neither Bolson
nor Lula is the relevant problem in
Brazil the problem in Brazil is that you
have a court that has seized all power
the censorship regime in Brazil makes
the United States look like this Bastion
of Liberty and freedom and at the same
time you have these corrupt factions in
Brazil that continue to run Brazil to
the detriment of 90 of the population
um and so I seen bolsonaro with neither
as villains or Heroes
um they're almost ancillary figures more
than they are Central figures to
Brazilian politics you know when I when
I talked to some friends there the way
they describe Lula is like criminal at
the highest level corrupt uh politician
you know stealing money from the people
he had a meeting with Castro yeah didn't
him Castro have a meeting at like 83
years old Castro was a an emotional
meeting with Boston no years ago 13
years ago will I maintain positive
relations with Hugo Chavez with Medora
with Castro but at the same time it's
kind of weird don't you think
I don't think it's weird to have
relations with some of the most
important leaders of the most I mean
Venezuela is a country with enormous oil
reserves totally get it yeah um you know
I mean Joe Biden meets with the head of
Saudi Arabia
um who is as repressive as anything that
that Hugo Chavez ever did or that Fidel
Castro did we have a long history of
supporting tyrannical government I'm not
trying to defend law or I'm not trying
to defend bolsonaro there's huge
political polarization the Brazilian
right sees Lula the way that the
American left sees Trump and at the same
time the Brazilian left wants Boston
Ireland prison and is well on their way
to putting bolsonaro in prison they've
already made him ineligible to run
um without even convicting him and I
think a lot of those methods are
anti-democratic as well I'm you know I'm
uh for me when I see stuff like that
happening and you know Brazil uh uh
being the great people that they have
there and you saw a similar thing but
not bolsonaro can't go there they have a
guy at the top who's the the one that
everybody fears is he the attorney
general who looks like a bat you know he
just looks like a guy that presents
everybody
yeah that's right there pull up his
picture he looks real Tyrant that guy is
a real Tyrant well whose side is it
people aren't more on Lula than he is is
in 2017 when he was in nominated for the
Supreme Court the less hated that guy
look he looks like
stuff this guy's done this guy is this
guy is scary there are very few people
willing to criticize Alessandra Mirage
I've been using my platform non-stop to
warn about the dangers that he poses to
Brazilian Liberty you feel safe with
this guy there no no I don't this I'm
surprised he hasn't come after you yet
the reason he wants to believe me the
reason he can't is I have a I I took I
accepted a contract with Brazil's
largest newspaper which is like the New
York Times of Brazil
um to kind of insulate myself further
obviously I have an international plot
form when Brazilian prosecutors tried to
indict me and prosecute me for the work
I did
um you know there became an interesting
candle no this guy is a this guy is a
fanatically I just kind of wanted to see
what you were for no this this is what
this is the guy who is responsible
somebody he runs Brazil he runs Brazil
even though he's a single member of the
Court no one has elected him wow and he
is a despot and a fanatic and the pure
sense of there what he will do is he
issues orders when he wakes up in the
morning ordering people banned off the
internet there was there's this guy he's
currently in Miami now you should talk
to him actually if you haven't met him
he was like The Joe Rogan of Brazil he
modeled his Constantino Rafael monarchy
is his name okay he modeled his show
after Joe Rogan he like has four hour
shows he drinks he smokes weed during
the show he became the most popular
podcaster in Brazil every politician
left and right was begging to get on the
show
he went on one his show he was a little
bit drunk he was asked is when he said
he was an absolute Free Speech
absolutist if that means even that the
government should allow the con a Nazi
party to exist and he said yeah of
course even the Nazi party should be
able to exist like a thousand United
States they turned they they called him
a Nazi YouTube kicked him off YouTube
his career was destroyed he went to
rumble he has a show on Rumble and now
that judge that fanatic that you just
put on the screen has ordered Monarch
are for off Rumble has fined him has
opened a criminal investigation he's
that's why he's in he he's he's in the
United States because he fears being
arrested the only thing that he has done
is question the Integrity of the 20 uh
22 election question a lot of the
orthodoxies of kovid
um without any trial that judge has
silenced what had been the most popular
it would be like putting it would be
like saying Joe Rogan is not permitted
to to use the internet but but to me
this is why I'm very curious because
some would say you helped Lula you know
when you you know when you talk to him
it's like okay maybe this because the
guy that you know people trust they
trust you so when you're doing something
you say something good about a guy but a
lot of people in Brazil say this is the
guy why Lula got you know he was able to
drop the charger so Lula could run
against Bolson there because they felt
like he was the guy that was the most
formidable guy to beat bolsonaro and he
did so I'll tell you what actually
happened and it's an interesting story
because it's repeating itself in the
United States and in the EU when they
put Lula in prison in 2017 the reason
they did it the establishment did it was
because they always wanted a
center-right kind of like a Mitch
McConnell Paul Ryan type that's their
dream to be to to run Brazil and the
only way they thought they could do that
was by destroying Lula and his party
what they got instead was bolsonaro so
they kind of got the monster that they
feared most and when bolsonaro got into
office they realized they feared
bolsonaro way more than they feared Lula
because he was a much bigger Enemy
No exactly so this guy here was an enemy
of the left the left hated him they
called him a racist and a fascist and
all the things the left calls people
when they dislike him and then what
happened was the Supreme Court The
Establishment realized there was only
one person who had any chance to beat
bolsonaro and that was Lula they used
our reporting as the pretext to let Lou
out of prison and to render him eligible
to run again look my reporting was
truthful I can't help the fact that the
Brazilian that the judge and the
prosecutors who oversaw Lula's
conviction did corrupt and illegal
things that's my job to reveal it and
not to hide it it's not my fault that
the that Lulu ended up winning they let
ooh out of prison because they knew only
luo could defeat bolsonaro dangerous
Skyrock that guy is I'll talk let me
tell you something these are very things
I've been a journalist for 20 years I
obviously have done a lot of Journalism
that has been risky has been dangerous
whatever there's never been a time not
ever in my life when I thought to myself
I want to criticize this political
official but in the back of my mind I'm
a little bit worried about the dangers
of doing so maybe I shouldn't do it the
only time that thought has entered my
mind was when I decided to go on a
public Crusade against him because he
has no limits on what he will do he
hasn't come after you yet
I'm going to stay in Brazil and I'm
going to continue to be the leading
voice against Alexander demarish because
I'm the one who has the the the the the
the flag he kicked a bunch of guys out
he kicked the former president's son out
saying you can't come back to Brazil
anymore look my my kids are Brazilians
are yeah
there's but but there's a big difference
between doing that to Brazilian
activists and doing it to me and so I
feel like I have the obligation with
this platform to use it because if I
don't who's going to be safe out there
respect Pat what are the chances that
you're going to invite our friend Glenn
and this guy Marias took Crustaceans
you know what it is when you're saying
this like I would love to go to Russia
and sit down with Snowden have a
conversation with them and I would love
to go have a conversation with Putin as
well obviously I'd love to talk to him
uh but we approached uh Maduro to go to
uh Venezuela to interview him because I
want to talk
who was the guy that was going up
against him that that's now in Columbia
yeah yeah just to learn what's uh uh
what's the reasons behind this stuff
that's going on but anyways you know it
is what it is uh Glenn uh it's great to
have you on uh uh I wish we could go a
couple more hours here with you I'll do
the last topic I just want to kind of
see what your thoughts are on this year
with the last topic ESG How concerned
are you with ESG there's anything with
ESG is going on story recently came out
about ESG uh on how these guys were
making all this uh momentum with Fink
State Street BlackRock all these guys
and the next thing you know BlackRock
ditches ESG shareholder proposals as
public pressure crowns BlackRock the
world's largest asset managers
reportedly scaling back support for ESG
related shareholders proposal support
and supporting only seven percent of
nearly 400 such proposals last year
significant drop from this historical 25
to 47 percent because so many proposals
were overreaching lacking economic Merit
or simply redundant they were unlikely
to help promote long-term shareholder
value and receive less support from
shareholders including Blackrock in the
recent years as his company's annual
review revealed despite the shift
blackrock's commitment to ESG goals and
influencing Banking and investment
persists the issue property agenda is a
66 trillion dollar weapon aimed directly
at Corporate America meaning this battle
is far from over over so
is it still around is it a concern is it
something that I I think the back I mean
I think everything that happened in 2020
and the excesses that that produced
because the fear that everybody had of
speaking out created enormous amounts of
backlash and I think what you're now
seeing is a kind of
um reaction to it there's I'm sure you
saw that story in the Wall Street
Journal about how corporations are
getting rid of their diversity managers
because they do nothing but create
problems and impede the performance of
the corporation and produce nothing of
actual real value because these kinds of
Notions of equality and diversity are
completely artificial they're offensive
they themselves are often steeped in the
very stereotypes that they purport to
combat and I think there's now a space
that has been created for these
companies to start to move away from
this
um I think there's a public demand for
it there's a shareholder demand for it
and I think that at least is headed in
the right direction okay I'm glad the
fact that we the people still have power
you know and the rowdier we are the
louder we are people are paying
attention to it uh Glenn you don't do a
lot of a face-to-face podcasts it's good
to have you we're honored to have you I
know when you and I met uh for the first
time two days ago we were chatting it up
and Chris is like uh Hey guys can we
reschedule that podcast and both of you
guys come to the debate and we made it
Friday exactly which kind of worked out
yeah so yeah great to be here we're
honored to have you trust me we are way
more honored to have you we've been
looking forward to this for a moment
your podcast folk we're gonna put folks
we're gonna put the link below system
update okay podcast that he run system
update available on Rumble Spotify Apple
podcast Google podcast and Pocket Casts
Rob let's put the link below both in
chat as well as uh in the description if
you enjoyed Today's Show with him trust
me you want to go subscribe to his
podcast because you get it there
regularly once again thanks for coming
on take care everybody have a great
weekend bye-bye bye-bye
Patrick David here from the Italian pbd
podcast look once a year we host a
conference called The Vault conference
it's our Super Bowl where 3 000
entrepreneurs CEOs executive sales
people from around the world come
together to spend three and a half days
together from August 30th to September
2nd at the Diplomat Resort in Miami to
learn how to scale their business how to
identify their next 5 10 15 moves who to
recruit next who to go raise their money
from how to raise Capital how to
properly skill culture retention higher
fire all of those things and much more
and we do that over a span of three and
a half days and the reason why it's a
very important season to attend a
conference like this the following
reason today there's three different
types of people they're scared they're
those that are content and the obsessed
they're scared they don't want to do
anything because they're worried about
what's going to happen in the economy
they're going to take a big hit the
content they're walking on saying life
is pretty okay I don't need to do
anything else and then there's the
obsessed because they see a massive
opportunity today so imagine spending
three and a half days with three
thousand obsessed people that want to
grow on a seasonal like this imagine how
much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event this is probably
the best lineup we'll ever have out of
all conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's going
to talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yeah this is my
recommendation to I never went to
conferences when I was coming up by
myself I always went with a spouse with
a business partner or running mate
because I only have a lens on what I see
every night afterwards we would sit
there and say what was your biggest
takeaway so get yourself your spouse
your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]